Done
Christine.
We're live.
We talked a lot before this podcast.
We even said we weren't gonna talk.
We're like,
I don't want to talk to you too much.
A lot of stuff to talk about,
but Dan,
we got into everything.
Christie Brinkley,
fibonacci sequence,
Tony Robbins,
Tony Robbins.
We covered a lot of ground crime.
Boyfriends as dogs,
as protective dogs.
Yes.
Protect it.
How did you get to become a life coach?
Oh Gosh,
this wasn't the worst.
No,
no,
no.
It's just,
it's not.
I never planned on it and I don't really
even like that.
That what's a good name?
I haven't come up with a better name for
it and let's come up with
maybe by the end of the show will come
up with something better so that that's.
That's your job.
Joe Got my new title by the end of the
show,
so I started out in Hollywood.
Actually.
I moved out after college to La because
mainly because growing up I was teased a
lot.
I was massively insecure and if you've
got something to prove,
Hollywood's a great place to come out
here to like,
oh,
fucking show you.
They'll show you.
Yeah.
I since I didn't fit in,
I didn't have a lot of friends and boys
didn't really ever like me unless they
wanted to cheat off my paper.
I became addicted to achieving and
that's like,
what can I be?
I want to be somebody like if only I was
somebody.
How old was I?
Oh Gosh,
when it started,
10,
eight,
something like that.
That's when you started like wanting to
prove yourself.
Not
Teasing started happening and that's
when I started to feel like I didn't
really fit in and I needed to find a way
to feel worth something.
So overachieving kind of became my way
to do that.
And then at 10 I was diagnosed with
depression and put on Prozac at 10.
I know that's what we'll bookmark that
combined.
And so from a very early age,
I really thought something was wrong
with me.
I didn't fit in and so I had to come up
with these compensatory strategies to
feel worthy,
to feel validated.
I feel like I mattered and so I just
became like straight a student addicted
to achieving,
went out to college.
I grew up in Texas,
went to northwestern,
graduated early and was just committed
to moving to Hollywood and working my
way up as an actor.
I mean,
as a kid,
I was an actor.
I tried that for a little bit and then I
was like,
Whoa,
this is way too much rejection.
I can't deal with this.
I want to go on the other side of the
camera and pursue this career in
Hollywood and I didn't know what exactly
I was going to do.
I thought I was going to be a producer
or something like that,
but I came out.
I was 20 years old and I applied to the
William Morris Agency to be an
assistant.
They're like,
you have to go through the training
program,
which is like pushing mail carts around
and I did not want to do that.
So somehow I got a desk like really
early and started working for the head
of TV packaging and quickly learned I
did not want to be an agent,
just didn't like it.
It was crazy long hours.
I was treated poorly.
It was just a hellish job and it was a
lot of selling and I didn't really like
that either.
So I left and actually went and worked
on the show.
You did?
I did.
I thought maybe I'll like production.
So first season as the man show I was
there,
which was kind of a blast and also just
crazy crazy show to work on.
I mean Jimmy and Adam were always like
super awesome to me,
but I was a young girl,
pa running around the jug dancers were
everywhere.
Like I just,
I was like,
what am I doing here?
So I quickly got out of production and
then started in comedy development at
paramount and started scouting comedians
and going to comedy clubs and finding
people that I could represent and bring
in,
maybe get deals for them.
And that quickly transitioned to moving
to another company where I was doing
comedy development and then I quickly
fell back into being an agent.
So that was like my first career was
like going to comedy clubs late at
night.
I'm at f two,
I think,
you know,
with the first client.
That was your first client.
That's fine.
I know Eddie very well was my very first
client.
We still keep in touch.
He says hi.
And that was like my life.
So here I am now 24,
25,
working at a big agency representing
clients.
I was the youngest female agent like in
the department,
maybe even in the city at that time,
I don't know,
it was really young,
got promoted really,
really super young and I was dating the
head of a movie studio and I was living
this amazing Hollywood life,
like making a lot of money going to the
Oscars and Golden Globes,
private jets.
Hanging out with celebrities,
like I totally had it all,
but I still wasn't happy.
It was like I had achieved one thing and
then there had to be the next thing.
And then I did achieve this and then it
had to be next thing you knew I'd get
the guy,
I still wouldn't be happy.
I get the promotion still.
I was on that constant chase and nothing
ever was like doing it.
So about two years I did this job,
I'm still on antidepressants.
I'm also taking antianxiety pills at the
time and just like trying to like manage
my life.
And I was one of those people that I
could really look good from the outside.
I could seem like I had it all together
and the inside was a totally different
story.
It's Kinda like a duck on water,
you know,
looks smooth.
But underneath it's like,
that's,
that was what I was like.
And you know,
a lot of people ask me about how to
achieve all this and still like suffer
from depression.
And I was a very functional depressed
person.
Like a lot of people think if you're
depressed you just lay in bed all day
and watch soap operas or something.
But that's not the,
that doesn't,
you know,
summarize all depression.
Like there's different ways it shows up.
And so I was able to live my life,
but I always felt like something was
missing.
I always felt like I wasn't enough and I
just had this heavy,
heavy energy and,
and,
and nothing I could achieve whatever,
filling that gap.
So let me keep going.
So,
uh,
one day I was riding up in the elevator
to work and I had basically a mini panic
attack.
I just couldn't breathe.
I got off the elevator and I just
couldn't catch my breath and was looking
at.
There was a lot weird foot painting and
art in our office and I was looking at
the weird photos and the one outside of
my desk was this woman in a negligee who
is nine months pregnant in this huge
yard sale with a Ufo light shining down
on her about to take her up.
And I'm looking at this painting.
I feel like that's me.
How did I get here?
Here?
And I just,
I walked,
I went back down the elevator,
walked around Beverly Hills and then
came back upstairs and I just wanted to
quit.
All I wanted to do was quit.
I thought that was the answer was just
like,
I quit my job and reinvent myself and
start over,
but I needed someone to give me
permission and so I called my dad
because my dad is has always been there
for me and I'm like,
Dad,
I really want to quit this job.
Can I?
And He did a really good dad thing.
Really pissed me off at the time,
but it was a good dad move.
You want to guess what he did,
so you get your shit together,
said I love you,
but I can't make this decision for you.
That is a good dad thing.
Get that thing.
And he hung up and I quit the next day
and that was the first really big risk I
ever took.
Why did you feel like you were the
pregnant woman with a Ufo about to take
you off in a flying saucer?
Felt confused and lost and like,
I didn't fit in and like chaos and it's
all wrong and how did I get here and
what has happened?
Isn't it crazy that Hollywood has so
many stories?
I mean,
not obviously,
not exactly like yours,
but so many stories of people who were
rejected and who have decided they're
going to come here to prove something or
to get the love that they need and what
do they run into.
They're in the business of rejection for
every.
Most people don't really think about it
because most people don't act,
but if you try to act,
you have to audition.
If you audition,
you're going to audition with hundreds
of other people.
They're all trying to get the same job
and they treat you like hundreds of
other people were trying to get the same
job.
It's the weirdest thing and people leave
and they're just devastated.
They're so confused.
They get nervous before the thing and
then they leave the thing and they feel
so helpless.
Yep.
It's the.
It's a strange,
strange business
really is,
and it's.
It's so often not based on talent.
No,
it's so often not based on who's the
best person for the job and that's what
frustrated me as an agent and also one
of the reasons I left.
I had a deal that I put together Eddie.
He was actually involved in it and my
boss made me attach a show runner who
like nobody wanted and but he needed the
police of that client and it killed the
shout and it killed these guys that
opportunity
all the time,
but happened to us.
When I took over the man show,
there was a show runner that there's
this,
this weird incestuous sort of fucking
business in Hollywood of connecting
people.
It's almost more about being social than
it is about anything else.
It's about making these relationships
almost like politics.
You become beholden to these people and
you get them jobs and they get you jobs
and you all just feed off of each and
y'all suck.
It really happens a lot.
It happens a lot with comedy writers.
Yup.
There's a lot of comedy writers that are
just,
you know,
there are.
They might have even been on Seinfeld or
something like a great show and there's
a few brilliant writers and there's a
few that are like,
what in the fuck is this guy doing here?
Well,
his agent is this guy's agent and that
guy,
agent force this guy in.
If you get that guy,
you get this guy too.
And they make these deals.
Exactly.
And that's what was so frustrating for
me.
If I'd have these really talented people
and I couldn't,
I couldn't get them jobs.
Why did they put you on Prozac at 10?
Do you,
were you an only child?
No,
no,
no.
I was the oldest,
the oldest.
How many kids?
Just to.
And I think,
you know,
my,
my parents loved me a lot and they just
were doing the best they could and they
were listening to doctors,
you know,
it was a time when,
if a doctor tells you something,
you listen,
what was bombing you out?
Like,
like what did,
what was it the point where they were
willing to put you on medication?
Well,
I think I went from when I was little,
I was really outgoing and talkative and
happy.
And then when the teasing and bullying
started to happen,
I completely just shut down.
Like I shut off particular group of
people that did it to one girl.
Well,
she's the one I wanted to mention when I
won my Oscar that was,
wanted to get up there and say get up
there and then eventually,
eventually I got over that,
but I just,
I,
I really just shut down and withdrew and
so it's just like.
Did you move to a different school or
was it just one particular kid?
They wanted me.
My parents were like,
go to a different school,
honey.
Like,
and I just wouldn't.
I was,
I was stubborn and I wanted to stay and
I think I was just scared,
you know,
that's the thing.
Like oftentimes what we know that's,
that's bad is safer,
feel safer than what we don't know that
might be better at my had a comfort zone
and where I was like,
even though I wasn't really happy,
like I knew that school,
I knew,
I was afraid that if I went to new
school I would just have to deal with
the same thing.
So I was just like,
I'll just stay where I am.
Isn't it crazy that you could run into
the wrong person when you're 10 years
old?
And it could fuck you up for a decade or
two.
Yeah.
But I think we,
I mean,
I don't know any human who hasn't had
something in childhood or adulthood or
whatever that is.
We can call bad jamie.
We're them.
Perfect.
Nothing's ever went wrong.
Nothing's ever gone wrong with you.
Just wait.
It's coming from
smooth and calm.
Young James collected.
Yeah.
No,
everybody's had difficulties.
It's unavoidable.
But w,
the bullying thing is very.
It's very strange how prevalent it is
and how it seems to be a part of human
nature that people have some strange
desire to find someone who's weak or
who's insecure or who is.
And then literally go after them and put
yourself in front of them and fuck with
them and ruin their life.
Their shit.
Let's go get her.
Like that kind of shit is.
It's a weird natural pattern that human
beings follow.
And I've always wondered like,
we need to talk to God sad about this.
Like what is the evolutionary basis for
that?
Like what is it about people that makes
them want to do that?
Especially young people.
Bull,
I don't,
you know,
and I think it's different with the
white girls do it in the way boys do
girls do it.
It's,
it's a little more sneaky and I think a
lot of times it's based more on jealousy
and that might have like,
I don't know,
that might have some girl unattractive.
No,
I think that um,
I was,
I was smart.
School came easy for me.
The teachers really liked me,
parents liked me and so I think that
that might have had something to do with
it and again I don't know,
you know,
is 10,
like I have no idea why they did what
they did,
but it was more sneaky like passing
around notes saying I joined the I hate
Christine club and like having everyone
sign it and just kind of quietly doing
it behind my back and pulling all my
friends way where I think boys are just
more aggressive.
Like they'll,
they'll beat you up,
they'll put you in lockers,
they'll do that,
that kind of thing.
But I think it's just a,
a power thing and you know,
within every bully as a scared little
boy or little girl.
So it's just,
I think how we were always,
not always,
but so much of the time we're trying to
compensate for something,
you know,
or refill less than where we feel
insecure.
We think if we can just have power over
something or somebody else that's going
to make us feel better.
There's also a thing that happens when
like the I hate Christine Club thing
where the other girls would probably
like,
I don't want to be on the end of that,
so I'm going to join in.
You get scared that they're going to go
after you next and you want to be on the
main team.
I think that's what's going on with
Donald trump.
I really do.
I think that's a lot of the reason why
people are with him and for him he's,
he's so vindictive and mean and the way
it goes after people,
I think you see a lot of people support
him and sort of like,
like cower to him.
Like even that Megan Kelly chick who's a
super brassy Badass ice princess,
she did that interview with him after
they had their little thing when she sat
down with them and she was.
She was so like submissive.
It was weird.
It was.
I mean maybe we should try to keep her
job.
Maybe Fox News where the riot act,
I don't know,
but it was really bizarre to watch her
tone down.
You ever see?
See the followup interviews?
Does.
She didn't.
She didn't call him out on anything.
Thanks.
She just.
No,
she was really submissive.
It was,
it was not what I expected it was.
It was very orchestrated.
I mean,
I think it was kind of obvious at that
point.
I don't know if he had,
he was the nominee or he was on his way.
It looked like all the other nominees
were falling apart and she did this
interview with her and him sat in some
office room,
like sat across from a table and it was
like people are scared.
People are scared of,
of the the strong man or strong woman,
you know,
the,
the person who's going to go after you
or the unpredictable,
like I think Donald is so unpredictable.
You never know what he's going to throw
at you and he,
he will go to whatever lengths he needs
to go to,
to humiliate,
to make you feel less than two to throw
you off your game,
you know?
So she probably was just like,
I better just,
well he just,
he sues so many people and so many
people sue him,
his,
that's his world,
you know,
and that's,
that's like a normal thing for him.
If he doesn't have a bunch of lawsuits
floating around the world probably feels
like nothing is even happening today.
Going to gotta get something going.
I got sue somebody crazy.
But I think that that,
that is one of the reasons why people
like are attracted to him because they
don't want to be on his bad side.
I think people were terrified of them.
You know,
super billionaire,
very famous,
big,
powerful guy.
I think there's a bunch of people that,
like with this,
I hate Christine Club.
If there was this one mean bitch that
just wanted to go after you,
there's probably a bunch of people that
would want to side with her just because
they're scared that she's going to turn
on them and start going after them next.
I think that's probably right.
Yeah,
for sure.
It's,
it's totally,
it's,
it's a tribal thing.
It becomes this weird,
like that's,
that's our leader now.
You gotTa,
you know,
a lot of leaders are the most vicious,
mean,
nasty,
terrifying people,
you know,
look at the dictators in Russia or Putin
or Kim Jong Una and what are they known
for?
The dictators and a lot of these Middle
Eastern countries,
they're fucking ruthless,
ruthless people and everyone's scared of
them.
So the whole goal behind them,
you know?
Yep.
Better to be behind them,
go up against them to feel the RAF.
Yep.
Yeah.
I think fear is a big motivator
unfortunately.
And,
and it I think impacts our ability to
really think clearly about something
because we're just so scared and so
threatened that we,
we stopped questioning,
wait a second.
Like what is he really saying?
When is he really leading me to?
Yeah.
Because that's the thing with Donald and
I talk to people who support him.
I'm like,
but do you do,
do you understand?
Like he would have more money if you
were to just like taken the money.
His father left him and invested it
versus all the bankrupting he's done in
the keys.
There's just so much that doesn't make
sense about him yet.
I'm just like,
okay,
well
it's never been a man alive that needs
mushrooms more than Donald Trump is.
There is.
I haven't heard of them.
I mean,
I'm sure.
I'm sure there probably has been.
But he needs him back.
He needs to go straight to the Amazon.
Yeah,
you might need to go right there,
but he needs something.
It's just,
he's,
he's almost like this super impulsive
huberous character.
Yeah.
You know,
everything is like when Hillary Clinton
says,
you know,
he doesn't pay taxes because.
Because I'm smart,
like he can't help,
like you're on the deer at a fucking
debate on TV.
You said you're smart because you don't
pay taxes.
Right.
Really reflects.
I mean it's not just him like it really
reflects like where we are as a society
that enough people support him to get
him to the place that he is.
I think we're so polarized right now and
like,
look,
I don't really love either candidate to
be honest.
I just don't.
But I think that.
I hope that maybe this is just wishful
thinking that will have four years of
whoever it is.
I think it will be hillary and then in
the next election we'll have people run
that we're actually excited about
supporting and voting for
maybe,
but I don't see those people anywhere.
The job one wants the job.
That's the problem.
It's a crazy job and it's a job where
they try to destroy you if you run for
it,
you know,
and you're seeing that with,
with trump and you're seeing that with
hillary and they're pulling out all the
stops and by the time it's over,
the opinion of the commander in chief,
it's going to be terrible no matter who
wins.
Right?
I mean there.
I mean that Crooked Hillary thing is
going to stick forever.
Hashtag Crooked Hillary.
That's gonna stick forever and People's
opinion of him is horrible.
You know,
it's no matter who wins and she's going
to win,
most likely,
but it's not good.
It's not good for any of us.
Nope.
It doesn't represent what we think of
the United States as we think of the
United States as being this unbelievable
place of creativity and innovation and
the greatest superpower the world's ever
known and this,
you know,
this really progressive force for good
in the world.
And you know,
I don't know,
maybe we need to go through this time
though to shake it up a little bit.
Maybe things need to get bad to get
better.
I mean,
I see that in human psychology so much,
you know,
you need to hit rock bottom,
you need to go through these hard times
so you have something better emerge that
maybe that's just wishful thinking.
No,
I think you're probably right.
I think we also needed to understand
because of the wikileaks revelations,
like how exactly politics is run.
Even with the people we think that are
the good folks,
like it's all fucking gross and dirty
and all the stuff with the Clinton
Foundation and all the stuff they did to
Bernie sanders and they conspired to
keep that guy out and there's.
I mean he's a Democrat too.
There are a whole.
The whole thing was supposed to be about
who is the person that best represents
the people with the people choose,
but now the Democratic National
Committee was fucking working to make
sure that Bernie Sanders wasn't the guy
and they were all conspiring with
Hillary and they're all pulling favors.
This just like we were talking about
before with producers and networks.
It's the same shit.
It's just using your power and your
influence and all the friends that
you've made and all the years and all
the favors and and pulling it together,
but now we're being exposed to it in a
way that we haven't really,
since Watergate,
Watergate gave us like a little window,
a tiny little window,
but the access to information was so
minuscule back then,
like we clung to those 15 minutes of
whatever,
Watergate tapes,
whatever it was,
and we look at this.
I'm not a crook.
He was doing what they were all doing.
He just got caught and we got to.
We got a sense of it now,
but now when you read these emails,
but how they really feel about each
other and all the fucking gross list
that goes on.
Well,
I try to not engage too much in the
gross ness because it's just like,
what's the point?
I guess the point is to understand what
the world really is about.
What the structure,
the government that looms over us is
really all about.
Why are certain things legal?
Why certain things illegal?
Why are certain loopholes in place?
How did they get in place?
Who benefits from them?
What is a charity and if it is a
charity,
how come you get paid so much?
Like how come you get paid $250,000 to
speak and then all this money goes to
your charity,
but that $250,000 goes to you.
Like you just talked for an hour.
Like this is a scam,
but that's the thing like you're asking,
you're being curious,
being curious.
You're asking questions and I think
that's helpful.
I think what so many people are doing or
just getting mad and just trash talking
in America and the candidates and and
that doesn't do any good for anybody.
If you want to like ask questions and
get involved and start to get curious
and quest,
that's,
that's awesome.
That's how we change things,
but I think too much of this has just
been so emotionally driven that people
are just getting upset and not really
going home.
What can I do?
What can I learn?
How can I shift this in some way?
Yeah.
It's also people are like super psyched
to get behind their candidate.
Third team.
I got to tell you like there's a lot of
gross on both sides for sure.
There's a lot of grossness on the trump
side.
There's a lot of mean assholes that have
finally found another mean asshole
that's running for president and they're
pumped like he's one of them,
but then there's a lot of men who are
using Hashtag.
I'm with her and they're the grossest
little fucking white knights.
Oh my God.
I've run across a few of them on
twitter,
like a white knight.
You don't know what a white knight is.
How dare you.
You really don't know like a knight in
shining armor.
A man who comes along comes along and
positions himself as the superior
morally superior to call Michael Shermer
calls a virtue signaling as someone who
would would say Hashtag,
I'm with her Hashtag male feminist,
you know,
Hashtag.
That's real.
There's a lot of those out there.
Yeah,
they.
They're trying hard.
They couldn't get laid in any other way,
and this is,
this is the strategy.
There was the strategies to position
themselves as the super progressive.
Yeah.
It's like people who don't want you to
think that they're racist,
so they go out of their way to
discriminate against white people,
other white people when they're white.
I read this thing with this woman was
saying,
if you are a white person and you were
up for a job and you are up against a
person of color,
do period not period.
Take that job.
You don't deserve it.
Examine white privilege.
I was like,
oh my God,
what Liberal Arts College do you belong
to?
What fucking crazy shit is in your head?
Like what?
I don't get it at all.
Period.
Not Period.
Take that job.
Yeah,
well you don't have to get it.
We went on a tangent.
We went off.
We were trying to find out how you
become a life coach and all of a sudden
you're talking politics,
White,
White Knights.
I love it.
Yeah,
and now I now I know a whole new
understanding of white nights.
Well,
I always understood it as,
you know,
the man who's going to come in and
rescue
that would,
they're positioning themselves as that,
but that,
you know,
I think we're a couple decades away from
all this going away because I think
technology is going government going
away,
all bullshit,
all bullshit and lies.
I really believe this.
I think technology is going to enable
just like no one anticipated.
As you can go back to the first days of
cameras,
if you went back to the 18 hundreds,
they first had a camera.
No one would have ever thought that in
the lifespan of just.
I mean,
what was the first camera?
Jamie?
Like 18 slash 60,
something like that.
Like civil war era was like the first
cameras.
No one would've ever thought that in two
lifespans,
which is essentially what it is from
then to now,
you'd be able to send video to Australia
instantaneously from something that
slips into your pocket,
find blind when he like,
stop
to think about how much we've seen in
our lifetime.
Yeah.
I think we're just so used to it.
We're so used to google and the Internet
and when Hillary Clinton was telling
like Donald Trump said something and
she's like,
Google it,
Google what?
He said,
it's not true,
and it was like how hilarious is that
Hillary Clinton is telling people to
Google Donald trump.
Like that's,
that's how beautiful access to
information is today.
I think we are a couple decades,
maybe a little bit more away from a
completely new paradigm,
a completely new way of accessing
information.
I think we're going to submit to
something,
whether it's a neural implant or some
sort of augmented reality and we're
going to be able to read intention and
thoughts.
It's going to be there's not gonna be
any lying 100 years.
I really believe that.
Totally think you're right.
And I think that's why we're seeing so
many of these systems break down like
the presidential election,
which used to be this coveted amazing
thing.
Now we're kind of looking at it like
it's,
it's a reality TV show.
That's what it seems like now
is all pussy grabbing,
craziness,
craziness.
That's the believe that
first,
like 20 minutes of the second debate.
Well,
I had been out of the country for a
month,
which was so refreshing and to come back
and I watched it and the first 20
minutes was just character slams.
It was nothing about nothing,
about the issues or anything and I was
just like,
what,
what's,
what's happening?
That doesn't make me happy.
Like it doesn't make me feel like if he
shits on her,
she shits on him and she,
she tears him down.
It doesn't make me feel like she's
better.
I liked her and one of the debates
because I didn't tune into it until the
last hour and he was saying a bunch of
crazy shit and she would start laughing.
I was like,
that's how she should handle him.
She should handle him like he's a child.
Like if she did that,
but she's fucking crazy too.
So depending president of another
tangent,
lots of fantasy life coaching.
How,
how do you go from.
All right,
so we're running mad at both of us,
by the way.
I'm sorry.
Suitable politics.
Yeah.
How about you just shut the up.
I will totally own that.
I,
that's not my area of expertise.
That's what nobody knows shit about
politics,
even the people doing it.
That's why Donald Trump's running for
fucking president,
nobody saw that common,
you know,
and nobody understands this stupid
system.
Yeah.
But You understand life coaching.
I see.
Yes.
We're going to come up with a better
name,
but her name and that's our live
coaching.
Yes.
But,
so the way it happened is
um,
all right,
so I quit my job,
which threw me into an even worse
depression because that was my whole
identity,
like it was my success in being an
agent.
And so then in a period of,
I don't know,
like six to eight months,
a bunch of things happened,
I went into lots of debt because I tried
to keep up with this lifestyle.
I,
um,
was a strange from my family for a bit
because I made a choice that they didn't
really like.
And I got diagnosed with another
autoimmune disorder on top of everything
else.
And then I was engaged and thought,
oh,
I'm going to be a wife.
Like that's my next role.
I'll be fine.
And then six months before my wedding,
he dumped me cultivating.
So I in that,
you know,
I know people listening to I've been
through worse,
but in that like span at 26 years old,
losing my career and money and family
and health and love,
it was Kinda like this sucks like this.
I really didn't know what to do.
And I had honestly a moment on my
bathroom floor,
which I don't know why I was on my
bathroom floor was disgusting,
but she was laying there.
It's a good spot to cry the tiles and
nice and cold,
you know,
it feels very dramatic and I had this
like kind of insight I guess you could
say,
of how much I was relating to everything
as a total victim as like everything was
happening to me.
And then it dawned on me I'm the common
denominator in like all of these
situations.
So either I have just really bad luck or
I have some influence over this.
And again,
like it was just a teeny bit of an
insight.
But it was enough of a new perspective
on my life that kind of got me off the
bathroom floor and started to give me
some kind of hope and started to make me
realize I needed help and like I,
the way I was doing my life wasn't going
to work anymore.
And so I found,
I thought I was having a quarter life
crisis and I found a book by that name
and I read it and it was fine,
but it wasn't going deep enough for me.
So I decided to write a book about like
my experience and everything I was
learning and how I like was getting
myself off my bathroom floor I guess.
And I was interviewing people for the
book and they kept saying things to me
like,
can I set up a session with you?
And I'd say why I got all the
information.
And they said,
well,
aren't you a coach or a counselor or
something?
And I'd say no.
And they said you should be,
you should be,
you should be.
And I kept hearing this over and over
and over again.
So I went to my coach and kind of my
first teacher who I met when I was 22
and I was still seeing,
she has had a major impact in my life
and I said,
Mona,
you know,
everybody's telling me I should do this
and I've been looking for my career for
years,
maybe this is what I'm supposed to do.
She's like,
Yep,
that's what you're supposed to do.
And I got out,
I've been coming for five years,
like,
why didn't you tell me this?
And she said,
you know,
you had to figure it out,
you had to find it.
And so that's how it just started.
Like people kept reflecting back to me,
hey,
you're good at this,
you should do this.
And I didn't really know how or what.
And so then I just became,
I started studying it.
I apprenticed with her,
I got training,
I got a master's degree,
I wrote more books and it just sort of
happened out of my own life and out of
just creating things that I thought
would help people and people going,
actually,
this is really helping me and can I talk
to you more?
And that was,
you know,
a good 10,
11 years ago.
Have you pushed the mic forward a little
bit more and make the sound consistent?
It's,
it sounds good in your ear.
Just the recording.
You'll be weird.
It is an interesting thing that it's
oftentimes small choices that people
make that dictate what happens to them
in their life.
But if you just decide that things are
happening to you,
you don't take any responsibility for
any of the choices.
That's,
to me the biggest difference are people
who are able to change their life and
people who don't is ownership,
is realizing that yes,
things happen but we're not victims and
anything can happen,
but at the same exact thing happened to
you and I and we can make different
choices about what we make it mean and
how we respond to it and we're going to
create different results based on that.
So it's not what happens to people.
It's not just luck.
It's truly what are you going to choose
to believe about it.
And that's to me the key differentiator
between staying where you are and kind
of regressing as you get older and just
repeating you're familiar patterns and
prints and repeat life and more stubborn
and all those things and you know,
just looking for those short term bursts
of happiness and like a trip or a bottle
of wine or whatever versus like really
getting clear about how you can change
your life,
what your purpose is,
what brings you joy and like who you
really are.
There's a thing about life coaching to
or any,
but I mean,
just to forget that word,
but the idea that your dispensing advice
or giving out inspiration or you know,
writing things down that have affected
and helped an enhanced you,
people want to dismiss that stuff like,
oh,
I don't need that.
Oh,
that's nothing,
but I feel like one of the best things
about being a part of a community or
being a part of a culture is that you
get to look at all of the things that
people have done that have benefited
them and all of the,
the positive choices that someone is
made and you can learn and experience
those without having to go through all
their bullshit.
Yeah.
You know,
and there's a lot of things that I've
learned from people whether I've read
things that they've said or listen to
speeches that they've given about
mistakes that they've made.
Where I've come across a similar moment
in my life when my ob,
I've,
I know what this is,
I know what that is.
It's,
I think it's one of the best tools that
we have.
When,
when,
when it comes to improving and enhancing
your own life,
your own individual experience is
looking at all the different shit that
other people have done and it's a.
it's a weird one because people dismiss
it so easily.
They don't,
first of all,
they dismiss it at A.
There's a certain amount of Hubris and a
certain amount of ego attached to it
where they don't want to admit they have
an issue or they don't want to admit
they need help or they don't wanna admit
that they need to be inspired or they
need some sort of motivation.
I think it's.
Yeah,
I think it's fear.
Yeah.
That whole,
this life that I know is comfortable.
I may not like it,
but I'm so scared of uncertainty that I
don't want to make the changes.
You know,
people are terrified of the unknown.
There's also a lot of fuckery of foot
when it comes to life coaches and
motivational speakers and there's a lot
of hosers like we were talking about
before,
the podcast,
about a couple of hoses.
We know there's hosers out there and
those people,
but it's like everything else.
Like,
you know,
there's bad car mechanics,
they'll put a used part and your car and
fuck you over this.
There's bad doctors,
there's bad everything.
Everything in this world as someone
who's half passing it.
And the problem with that whole,
the idea of being a life coach or being
a motivational speaker is that there's
not really,
like,
you don't have to get a phd to do it.
You don't have to,
you know,
you don't have to like prove yourself.
Like Mike has opened up 15 different
businesses,
so he's going to show you how to do a
business.
Like this guy's a successful
businessman.
That makes sense.
But there's a lot of people out there
that are doing life coaching that are
fucking failures.
Yeah.
And maybe maybe that's not the worst
thing in the world to be a failure
because you've learned from those
failures and maybe your achievement or
your contribution is expressing those
failures and your revelations from those
failures and that can help somebody else
not make those same mistakes.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think I've had a lot of so called
failures and mistakes.
Um,
did you ever have one of those like
bathroom floor moments?
So it's like life pivot.
Oh Man.
First of all,
check on the floor.
Yeah.
I mean I'm not all bullshit aside.
Yeah,
there's always um,
for,
for a comic,
the big one is bombing.
Bombing on stage is devastating and you
start thinking like,
I can't,
I can't do this.
Like you can only take so many of those
bombings in your life.
It's like getting beaten up.
You can only get beaten up so many times
before,
like your brain stops working.
Right?
And there's that relationship breakups
for sure.
Um,
devastations I think are always the best
for a rebirth.
And at the time they don't feel like it.
No.
And devastations anything devastating
that happens to you in your life while
it's happening.
You feel like,
I don't know if I can take this,
but then you get through it and you have
this sort of enhanced perspective.
And then you also,
we live in an amazing time where you can
see,
you know,
not that you should revel in other
people's failures,
but you could like,
look what most of your failure is.
Nothing in comparison to what's going on
in a million like Syria or million
different parts of the world that are
just filled with fucking chaos.
Most people can't see that because you
see your life and your life is all,
you know when your life is falling
apart.
Right.
Well,
and I think too,
you know,
we get so kind of narcissistic and our
problems that we forget the bigger
perspective and we don't.
A lot of people talk about being happy
all the time.
You should be.
And I just don't think that that's real.
I think that you,
I've grown and I through contrast
through,
you know,
I,
I think I really understand happiness,
enjoy because have really understood
depression and sadness.
Like that polarity I think is such a big
part of what we're here for.
Yeah.
I mean you look at your read a book
about different parts of the world and
what's going on.
You if you're still happy to read that
book,
something wrong with you,
you know,
like,
probably shouldn't be happy all the
time.
There was actually,
I think it was scientific America or
something like that that had an article
recently saying you're not going to be
happy all the time and you shouldn't be.
And there's an a,
there's a reason for it.
There's peaks and valleys in everything
in life.
Yep.
And that I,
you know,
for people listening that might be in
one of those valleys,
it's like,
don't try to just get through it,
really ask,
you know,
why,
what can I learn from this?
That was my biggest thing is I stopped
asking why is this happening to me?
And started asking,
what can I learn?
Yeah.
So instead of painting yourself as a
victim,
you paint yourself as someone who's
present in the moment and just,
okay,
I don't want to do this anymore.
Let's figure out what's going on.
Exactly.
And we don't.
A lot of times we don't have the tools
and that's where things like life
coaching and personal development come
in handy is cause we can go and get
those tools instead of using our old
coping mechanisms by like being strong
or overseen overworking,
overdrinking over,
do you know,
jumping into a relationship like
whatever it may be.
We,
we don't really learn how to deal with
disappointment,
failure,
anger or shame,
any of those things.
And so we're kind of left to these quick
fix devices that in.
I think that's a big reason addiction is
such a problem is because we don't
really learn how to manage emotion and
how to manage this appointment.
And so we go for that thing that makes
us feel better in the moment.
But the problem is we have to keep
upping the ante.
You know,
at first that one glass of wine does the
trick,
but then you need to then you need
three,
then you add vodka,
they whatever it may be.
And so I,
I mean,
why I'm so passionate about what I do
is,
first of all,
I never,
I never thought I could be happy.
Like I really didn't.
I thought that this,
you know,
I was going to be depressed and I just
was gonna constantly be looking for
something to fix me.
I never really truly thought this life
that I'm living now was possible.
Again,
externally things look fine.
But internally I'm talking about a
totally different kind of experience and
it's only because of those like really
awful moments.
I call them expectation hangovers that I
was kind of desperate enough to let go
of my normal coping mechanisms and my
trying to control everything.
It was like the ultimate and surrender
truly of going okay.
Like I don't,
I don't know,
I need to find a different way to deal
with this.
And that's really what has led me down
the path that,
that I am today.
So,
you know,
I,
I think that life coaching and the
personal transformation industry and all
that.
Like you said,
there's a lot of,
what'd you call them?
Hoke cookies.
Posers,
posers,
Bob and Doug.
Mckenzie,
I don't even know who that is.
Fucking 19 eighties.
Siren live character for college to the
posers there from a Canada.
Oh my God.
It hoser mean those guys.
I don't know why.
Why hosers learning all these words.
This is great.
Why hoser?
I don't know why that.
I hardly ever use that.
I don't know why it popped up.
I love it.
I want to go back to the.
The PROZAC?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Because I'm super.
Your parents put you on that stuff when
you're 10 years old.
I think it was more the doctors.
Doctors.
I'm sorry,
your doctors put you on that stuff when
you were 10 years old.
Tests and blood tests.
What do you see a demon?
What do you see?
Death.
A skull?
I probably said things like a butterfly
of pitch.
I hate from school with fucking ax in
her head.
So the doctor puts you on PROZAC.
And what kind of an effect does that
have on you?
I mean,
it actually helped.
It really helped.
I think it helped me.
Um,
gosh,
it's so hard to remember too.
I mean,
I was 10,
but when I talked to my parents about
it,
they're like,
you know,
it did help because I really do think
that because of everything that
happened,
you know,
my brain chemistry did shift,
I do think that we can shift our brain
chemistry with repetitive thoughts and
you know,
I had enough thoughts about,
I'm not likable.
I had just intense inner critic in my
head and I do think that shifted my
brain chemistry and I do think that the
medicine helped me at least get to a
point where,
you know,
I was like kind of awake again.
How long does it take?
I don't remember,
but I know that,
you know,
especially in my twenties,
like I'm still on it.
Oh Gosh,
I was on it until 30.
Yeah,
I was on every from every.
I was on Prozac,
Wellbutrin
for many years.
20 from the time you were 10.
So all through high school you run that
stuff?
Yep.
Wow.
I,
I believed that I needed it just like a
diabetic would take insulin.
So how long ago did you get off of it?
A seven and a half years ago.
Wow.
And,
and like totally,
I,
I never have any regression or dips but
I did.
I was super intentional about getting
off of it.
I didn't just stop like,
especially after 20 years.
It took me a while.
It took a lot of the emotional work that
I was doing with my coach Mona because
so much of depression is suppression so
you know,
and all that stuff was happening.
I think I was pretty angry about it but
I had no outlet for that,
especially as a girl like boys again can
go out and get stuff out.
But a lot of times,
and this is why I think so many women
get irritable and bitchy and all those
kinds of things is because women,
we don't have like that outlet for
anger.
And so we internalize a lot of that.
Like we can do sadness but anger a lot
of times gets suppressed.
And so a lot of like me getting off my
medicine and not feeling depressed was
not being suppressed.
Exercise the exercise is okay,
but until you like go back and actually
process the emotion.
I mean,
exercise is good in terms of moving the
energy,
but a lot of times you have to attach
like the feeling with the movement,
right?
So like a lot of my retreats that I do
where I just bring women,
I facilitate like an anger barn for
them,
anger,
burn,
what is that?
It's like a safe place for women to get
their anger out.
Like,
and it's not just catharsis,
like there's a whole kind of process I
put them through so they like,
you know,
kind of reconnect maybe earlier life
experiences where they didn't feel
protected or they felt unsafe or they
felt you know,
abused or whatever that is.
Because again,
like this is just,
this all comes from my own life
experience in working with,
Gosh,
thousands of people at this point.
Like I,
I see over and over again.
People that are depressed,
shut down,
have a lot of anxiety,
not happy with their life,
have some like,
unprocessed thing from their past that
just needs to move.
And when I create this space for people
to start to move that energy,
it's like underneath there is creativity
and passion and peace and freedom from
anxiety and all that kind of stuff.
So when you're looking at me like
he's looking at me like,
who is this girl?
So when people have that space to
unleash that and to let the energy move
through them because I think there's a
difference between emotion and feelings.
So feelings to me,
our physiological responses to thoughts.
Okay.
So if I sit here and think about the
future of that I'm scared about,
I'm going to feel anxiety.
If I have like,
oh my gosh,
what if someone breaks into my house
tonight,
I'm going to feel fear.
You know,
if I,
I can,
I can feel regret because of a thought
or guilt.
But,
but emotion like energy in motion,
if someone hurts one of your kids,
you're going to experience anger.
You know,
like it's a natural response.
Someone close to us dies or we have a
heartbreak.
It's natural to feel the emotion of
sadness.
And I think that there's a lot of kind
of misleading information about like,
oh,
we create all our feelings with our
thoughts and we can just affirm our way
out of things and think our way out of
things.
And to some degree that's true.
Changing our thinking does a lot.
But with,
with some core emotions like anger,
shame,
sadness,
I think we got to feel them and I think
that that's what people are really
scared of is actually kind of opening
that box,
opening that can of worms and going back
and actually feeling those feelings.
But the thing is they're in there.
And so if you don't get them up and out
in a healthy way,
then I think that's what creates a lot
of suppression,
a lot of depression,
perhaps,
maybe even disease,
things like that because they just get
stored in our body somewhere.
It makes sense.
So what do you do to these gals?
What do I do to these gals?
Um,
I,
it's just creating the space.
They just scream,
well,
you know,
it's not a pill.
No,
it's not that I give them.
I definitely give them something to hit
with,
like in those foam noodles,
you know,
that
I do and oh gosh,
the comments to this are going to be
crazy.
I can't believe this,
but here we go.
So I um,
and I put on some pretty intense music
and again,
I don't even know.
Not slayer,
not slayer.
Slayer.
It's more like,
it's more like metallica.
Metallica is on my playlist.
I'll,
I can pull up my place.
I really want to see it.
Um,
you have a beat the shit out of a foam
roller.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's cool.
Anger,
burned platelets.
burned playlist.
Yeah.
Well I'm telling you a little bit about
actually.
So one time I was doing this,
I rented a house actually out in the
near here,
a Gaura and people were doing this
process and again,
like I prep them,
like the,
you know,
I,
they,
they bring to mind things that they've
maybe,
like I said,
like we're angry about things from their
childhood,
you know,
it's not just like a throw them in a
room with loud music and say go after
it.
Like they're very,
there's a lot of processes I put them
through to get them to this point.
But anyway,
so we're doing this one time in this
house and there's like 20 women,
loud music yelling and um,
the cops show up
and
the guy's like,
what do you like,
what's going on here?
And I step out,
I stepped out and I explained,
I said,
you know,
a lot of times I,
this is a women's workshop and a lot of
times,
you know,
we,
we hold back our emotions and you know,
we ended up getting irritable and it's
just as healthy way for people to,
to heal and work on their emotions.
And the cop looks at me and he's like,
can I have your card?
I want to send my wife.
No kidding.
That's what the cop said to me.
So is.
And I've gotten lots of calls from
husbands and boyfriends and even kids
and like thank you because there's
something about,
it's like pulling off our armor
honestly.
And there's something about doing like
the deeper work and kind of going to
those scary places that takes a layer
off of us.
I think,
I mean it's similar to plant medicine,
a lot of ways of going to those places
where that are Kinda like,
hmm,
where you come out the other side and
you have a deeper understanding of,
of yourself.
Um,
so by doing something completely
ridiculous and crazy and just letting
loose and all the madness involved with
it,
it's almost like a reset
for you.
Yeah.
And it's not,
again,
like it's facilitated.
It's not this,
this crazy,
you know,
people going into screaming,
it's not fight club.
It's not because there's a difference
between catharsis and like actual
processing stuff,
but it's just.
And again,
I think we,
we don't really understand emotion to a
certain level and we think that big
emotion is crazy and it's not
necessarily.
I think what is crazy,
what makes people crazy is suppressing
it their whole life and trying to manage
it through their mind or through doing
things or through whatever else versus
actually like being willing to look at
those parts of ourselves because we're,
you know,
we're humans.
We have a mind,
we have emotions,
we have actions,
we have,
you know,
our spiritual self,
whatever you want to call that,
like something that's connected to
something bigger than us and I think we
need a holistic approach to really
change.
No.
From the time that you decided to get
off of the antidepressants,
did you follow a protocol?
Did you go to a doctor to discuss it
with them?
Did you read anything about how to do
that and what advice would you give to
anybody out there that might be
listening that also is going through
that same sort of situation?
Um,
doctors told me I couldn't do it,
so yeah,
definitely good doctors ever stay on and
I'm getting paid exactly.
Um,
so I had,
you know,
my coach at the time,
he was really helpful who more than,
again,
like coaches such like a,
I don't even know what to call her.
She was,
how did you find her?
I was dating a guy who was an addict and
complaining about him to girlfriend at
lunch for like the 80th time.
And she said pill.
No drugs like coke,
alcohol,
maybe pills and pills to fun times.
Good Times.
Hollywood.
Super Great.
Yeah.
I was popping xanax while he was doing
all that.
So anyway,
I,
I'm,
I've totally lost my train of thought.
Oh,
how'd you find your coach?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I had to find a coach.
So we're sitting at lunch.
I'm talking about this for the 80th time
and she goes,
I can't,
I can't listen to this anymore.
I went and saw this kind of cookie woman
go see her.
So and I had been to shrinks my whole
life and I'd never been to like a coach.
I had always been to therapists and
psychiatrists and so nothing against
therapists and psychiatrists.
They do good work,
but I had kind of like reached my limit
with it and so I go to this woman's
house and she's like totally stuck in
1985,
like her decor,
her fashion,
everything.
And I sit down and I sit across from her
and she didn't even see me in a normal
office.
I think she knew she needed to like
totally get me out of my comfort zone.
So she put me in her son's bedroom with
like these race car bunk beds and I'm
sitting there on this race car,
bunk bed,
the going,
where am I,
how did I get here?
And she walks in and she sits in front
of me and it was the first time in my
life and I felt loved by my parents.
This was the first time in my life I
felt really seen,
like it was almost uncomfortable.
Like this woman could almost see through
me.
She could see me,
she could really see me and I felt zero
judgment from her,
like zero and although is scary and a
little bit because it was like kind of,
I felt very vulnerable if there was
something so reassuring about it because
she was the first like practitioner I
had seen that didn't see me as broken.
She really just saw me and she was the
one that in so many ways helped me over
the years,
get off the medication by teaching me
how to release my emotions.
Um,
by helping me understand that,
you know,
bad feelings aren't necessarily bad.
I also got very clear about my diet,
like I got off gluten because a lot of
times gluten can impact brain chemistry.
Um,
I stopped drinking.
I wasn't never a big drinker,
but I stopped drinking for about two
years because alcohol's a depressant.
I'd always been into exercise and
fitness and eating healthy and
everything like that.
Um,
and then I also started meditating and
like finding some kind of connection to
a higher power.
I didn't really have a name for it at
the time,
but something where I didn't feel like I
was so alone because that was kind of
one of the scary things about
depression,
you feel you feel alone a lot of the
time.
And so it was a combination of all of
those things that over time and the
belief that I could,
I really had to change my belief that I
could get off of them.
Um,
so for people that are considering it,
um,
don't just stop,
like,
it's dangerous just to stop because that
can really mess with your brain
chemistry.
Find somebody who knows something about
this and can put you on a plan,
can help you,
you know,
I'm not a doctor,
I'm not here to get met,
get given medical advice so,
you know,
consulted doctor.
Um,
but for me it was number one,
the belief that I could and number two,
finding the people that could really
support me and number three,
making the lifestyle changes that I
needed to make to support it and being
willing to go to that dark,
scary place that I was afraid to go to.
What do you mean by when you say that
she was the first person who didn't see
you as broken?
Do what do you mean by they all?
They all saw you as broken
when,
you know,
for me,
when I would go to one of these doctors
or therapists,
I mean they'd see that I was on
medication since I was 10.
And um,
they kind of relate to me in that way.
Like as a person?
No,
just more like,
like I had a label,
you're depressed.
And so that's why they weren't willing
to consider you getting off of the
medication.
He felt like the medication is a part of
who you are.
You've got to accept it.
It's a daily thing.
It's like brushing your teeth.
You're not going to stop.
Yeah,
maybe.
I mean,
I don't even know what they were
thinking and I just know how it felt and
I just did it and it maybe it was
because like at the time I didn't
believe it yet either.
Maybe I need to someone who believed in
him.
I do think that also the people that
deal with people everyday,
whether you're a psychologist or a
psychiatrist or whatever,
that you're so inundated with people in
their fucking problems that after a
while you just become overwhelmed and
it's very difficult to see people like
and have a fresh reset.
Every time you see something like this
is a new person.
Her name is Christine.
Hey Christine,
what's going on with you?
Yeah,
I think you're right.
I think it's therapists,
psychiatrists.
They have hard jobs.
Like imagine your whole day is person
after person talking about what's wrong
with their life.
You know that that can be very draining.
Even when I first started as a life
coach and I saw person after person
after person,
I really had to learn not to take that
on and not to let it drain me.
Um,
so again,
like I have a lot of respect for my
mom's a therapist,
so I have a lot of respect for
therapists and psychiatrists are very
helpful to me.
I just think for me in my life journey
and what I wanted,
I,
I just,
I didn't want to spend the rest of my
life medicated.
I just really didn't.
So what is the difference between life
on medication and life off medication
and how long has the process of weaning
herself?
I mean,
I think it took me,
it took me a good two years to feel like
it was finally kind of out of my system.
Two years.
How long was it before you were actually
stopping taking it?
Um,
well I,
I,
Gosh,
I can't remember exactly,
but I think I,
I probably weaned for a good six months
and then it was like a year and a half
until I felt like it was like cleared
out of my system.
Wow.
So for six months you slowly wean
yourself off of it and then at the end
of six months you're not taking the
medication anymore,
but you still feel foggy.
Like what do you feel?
Yeah,
I wish it was,
it was like my system was recalibrating,
you know,
all my brain chemistry was recalibrating
and you know,
because that stuff affects your brain
chemistry.
It affected my hormones,
like it,
it just affected a lot.
So did you take like one pill and then
cut it down to three quarters of a pill?
I did consult to a psychiatrist and um,
they gave me like a winning plan.
So yeah,
whatever,
different people,
like it's not a standard thing,
like different psychiatrists will tell
you different things.
So it depends on what you're on,
how long you've been on it,
which medication you're on,
what the side effects for for it are
those kinds of things.
What does it feel like when you're first
day?
No pills.
Do you remember that day?
I remember the first day I woke up and I
felt clear like I felt like scientology
clear.
I don't want to keep getting kicked out
of here.
No,
I'm like,
like,
like it was like out of me and I was
oh my gosh,
I just felt like a fog and a heaviness
had lifted.
It just fell.
And I also felt like
I had deeper access to my creativity,
my intuition and all those things were
present,
but it was just,
there was just sort of like some white
noise there.
And I also like for me,
depression manifested as being
incredibly self critical,
like super self critical,
like this very,
very,
very loud inner critic.
And so that started to lift too.
But again,
I was doing all kinds of other work at
the same time.
You know,
I was studying with my life coach,
I was getting a master's degree in
spiritual psychology.
I was,
what is spiritual psychology?
Yes.
Good question.
So um,
this place called the University of
Santa Monica and I didn't know anything
about this place but I had been a life
coach and I thought okay,
if I'm helping people with their life,
I've got to know how to help them deal
with their past.
Like I can't just work on present and
future without like having some skills
for dealing with your past.
And so I was researching schools.
I thought if I could get a master's
degree in psychology that would help me
and that would be good for my career and
all those things to have some
credentials.
So I researched and I find this school
and I didn't really know anything about
it.
I'm like,
this is great.
And the spiritual part didn't have
anything to do with any religion or
anything like that.
It was more of the premise of,
you know,
that traditional psychology is,
is kind of a little bit more about
labels and,
and spiritual psychology is more people
have the inner resources they need to to
heal.
And I didn't again,
didn't know much about it,
show up at this school with my laptop
thinking I'm going to like take notes
and there's going to be lectures,
but it,
there are no desks.
It was a highly experiential school.
It's like I said,
a two year program and in that I really
learned how to um,
change my belief systems,
heal stuff from my past,
connect to a part of me because we all
have like our basic self,
like our conscious part.
But I,
I believe we also have something deeper
like art,
we can call it her intuition and we can
call it our gut feeling.
We can call it our authentic self,
but there's some kind of inner wisdom
that I think all of us have access to.
And this program really helped me get
more access to that,
that part of me.
So that I could start listening to that
more than my old conditioning.
My old belief system is my old fears
because,
you know,
when we're born we're kind of this blank
slate and then stuff happens and we
formed these stories about our lives and
who we are and how we get love and how
we get validation and how we get
acceptance and how life works and who we
are and our identity and it's kind of
just a story and we have,
we can change that story,
but it takes work.
Going back and deconstructing that story
and letting go of some old beliefs that
maybe we've hung onto to create a
different one.
So that's,
that's what so much of my journey has
been about is kind of looking at what's
the story I've created about my life and
how can I change it?
Because the story that I had was I'm
depressed.
I'm,
you know,
have to be achieving all the time.
Being hard on myself with how I motivate
myself.
So on and so forth.
I'm constantly rejected
Blahblahblahblahblah.
And by believing that story,
it was creating results in my life that
align,
that,
aligned with that.
And so to create different results,
I had to have a different story to tell.
And so there's this shift that that has
to take place and it's like turning a
battleship,
right?
It's not,
it's not a quick thing.
It takes a long time.
No,
it's,
it's not.
And I think that's another,
um,
kind of let downs people have when they
go to a seminar or read one book,
they expected change overnight and it's
a,
it's a process.
Do you remember the secret?
I do.
There was a girl,
I've told this story before,
but she was so nice.
She's friends with my friend Kelly,
Kelly,
Kirsten,
you know Kelly,
Christian comedian,
funny girl.
Anyway,
uh,
she was at the comedy store one night
and uh,
she was,
she was talking to Kelly and uh,
I was talking to her and she started
going on about her future,
all the things that she was going to do,
she was going to be married within a
year.
She was going to have the career that
she wants.
She was going to this and that and that
and this,
and uh,
I was so confused and she was like,
I found the secret I'm doing,
you know,
do you know about the secret?
I go,
oh,
uh,
the power of positive thinking,
I that kind of thing.
She's like,
it's not just that,
it's not just positive thinking.
It's like you do create your own future.
You create your own identity,
you create,
you create reality.
I was like,
okay,
like you sure?
And she's like,
yeah,
I'm sure you know,
I'm,
I'm positive.
Okay,
good luck.
I'm like,
boy,
the problem with all that stuff,
of course,
if you've never heard of it,
is what do they,
what,
what is the term for it?
They're trying to achieve law of
attraction.
Yeah.
What,
what they're trying to achieve is
they're trying to,
like,
you take the photo of your dream house,
you pin it on your wall,
you take a photo of a Ferrari,
you pin that on the wall.
You're going to get those things.
The problem is when you watch those
videos,
when they say,
you know,
I had this photo of my home on the wall,
I had the Ferrari that I wanted,
I had my dream life.
Now I have those things.
I,
I made those things happen with
intention and with thought.
Do you know many fucking people have a
photo of a beautiful house on the wall
and a Ferrari.
And they got no fucking house and they
got no Ferrari and they never will like
you.
It's,
you're taking it from a biased pool of
successful people who will tell you that
this happened to them.
But there are literally millions of
people who think positive and nothing
ever happens to them.
So this girl who,
um,
was a very nice person,
she came to one of my shows like a year
later and we're hanging out outside and
I go,
how's everything when you're doing?
She's like,
well,
it's really a drag,
you know,
because I was convinced that by this
time I would have all these things,
but you know,
my dad,
he's still,
you know,
fuck up and this and that and I've got
this problem,
that problem and I just don't understand
it.
I don't understand it.
I believe that I was so sure.
And we had this like,
really,
it was really interesting because she
was like two different people.
I got met her twice,
right.
So I meet her this one time and she's
just a glow with this delusion that now
she's got it and she's getting.
She was,
she was,
she thought also that talking about it
all the time was part of how you affirm
it.
So she was saying,
you know,
I'm going to be married in a year,
I'm going to do this.
I'm following the secrets.
She kept saying it and it was.
And then a year later she was just,
I don't get it.
It didn't work.
And so we had this sort of heart to
heart about it.
Haven't talked to her again and I don't
know what the hell happened to her,
but I'll never forget it because the two
different people,
the,
the girl who was like,
it was kind,
kinda crazy.
Like,
oh,
why I didn't believe in.
And then a year later,
year and a half I think just wasn't
happening and life was still kind of
shitty.
And she was,
she couldn't understand why the career
didn't happen and alive didn't happen.
And it's,
is all,
it's a slow shift.
It's a slow shift.
And I think the law of attraction can be
misleading because it's more,
you know,
change takes more than I put a picture
up and I do some positive affirmations
if like down deep you don't feel like
you're worthy or you're,
you're not going to be able to attract
those things.
You've got to like Kinda go back and
deal with core issues and core belief
systems in order to shift things in your
life.
I mean,
if it was as easy as putting pictures up
on our wall,
everybody would have,
you know,
lamborghinis and hot and wives and
husbands.
So,
but it,
it takes,
it takes more than that,
it takes being willing to like do some
work and take some responsibility rather
than just thinking the universe is Santa
Claus and just going to pop something
into your life
to people that are morbidly obese that
want a six pack,
like it can be done,
can be done.
But God damn you got a long road.
You know,
if you want to climb Mount Everest and
you're starting in Santa Monica,
you gotTa fucking get to Mount Everest.
Absolutely.
And then that's when people ask me,
how'd you get off antidepressants?
I'm not like,
oh well I just did this and then I did
this and then I this,
it was a,
it was years of like,
you know,
deciding I was going to and having the
right people around.
It wasn't,
it wasn't an easy thing.
It's probably the hardest thing I've
done.
No.
Now what is the difference between
antidepressants and Xanax?
Like when you're taking.
You said you were taking both.
Yeah.
Why do you need the Xanax if you're
already pilled up on the
antidepressants?
I mean,
again,
not an MD,
so not my territory,
but for me like I,
the antidepressants just kind of kept me
steady but then with my boyfriend at the
time and my crazy Hollywood life,
like I just had so much anxiety and you
know,
you go to a doctor and you're like,
I have so much anxiety though.
Do you want to or how do you define
anxiety?
Worried.
Worried,
worried a lot.
Like kind of high,
strong.
I'm not able to calm down.
Um,
yeah,
just that.
Just normal,
like anxiety,
but I didn't have tools.
Then my tools then we're medicine
now had better tools.
So now do,
do you take anything?
Nope.
And supplements,
supplements,
vitamins and stuff?
Yeah.
I'm super like I love human hacking and
human optimization.
I'm,
I love exercising.
I love meditation.
Meditation.
I take Alpha brain,
like all that stuff.
And you,
do you ever miss it?
Like is there ever a time we like God
dammit.
Popping Xanax and fucking glasses?
No,
no.
I will say this though,
when I had my eyes,
lasix lace Vino,
the Lasik and they gave me,
um,
value.
And how's this?
I see why people get addicted to this.
This is incredible.
I'm glad they did because I was super
freaked out about them cutting my
eyeball open and value them.
Just relax as you rise.
I would've felt great and then the only
time I ever did it.
But no,
I don't miss that because what I have
now is um,
like I,
I feel clear and alive and you don't
feel happy all the time.
I definitely have my days,
but I don't relate to it as I'm
depressed.
It's just like,
oh,
I'm having a normal.
Like,
you know,
human experience not having the best.
I think stories like there's a very
inspiring to people.
I think it's very important.
We don't want.
It's,
it's like it's hard for people to look
at people who aren't doing well and talk
to them and just go,
oh,
I don't know what to tell you a good
luck.
Let me get the fuck away from this
bitch.
You know,
like that's how people think.
Like I don't want to deal with her.
Problems are.
His problems are I,
I wanna,
I wanna I want to separate my and
concentrate on myself.
So I think when someone like you can
sort of express how you were in this
really bad state and yours is a very
bizarre situation because you're talking
about being on these pills from the time
you're 10.
Right.
That's,
that's really unique.
But then having almost a decade off of
them,
seven years off of them is.
Yeah.
I'm state.
And it's,
I,
I honestly think
it helps me help people.
Like it really does.
I've had lots of training as a life
coach,
but my own life experiences have been
the thing that's really given me the
most creative.
Sure.
I guess you could say,
what are your credentials are that
you're actually happy.
Yeah.
I'm actually happy I,
you know,
I,
I've been able to create a life and a
career and friendships and connection
that,
you know,
I thought I no longer live that story of
the I hate Christine Club.
I have great friends,
great women friends,
like all of that,
you know,
and,
and that's,
I know,
like different or more special than
anybody.
It's just again,
choices and I made choices that led me
to this point and everybody has that.
Everybody has that freedom.
What's the book?
Man's search for meaning.
Have you ever read that book by Viktor
Frankl?
He was,
yeah,
he was in concentration camps and he was
actually a psychiatrist,
I think,
but he talked about,
you know,
he kept himself saying and he kept
himself free through his mind and he
says in between stimulus and response,
basically what happens and how we
respond is a choice.
And in that choice lies our ultimate
freedom.
And I think that that's true.
That's,
that's what we all have.
That freedom,
no matter what your circumstances.
No.
When someone comes to you and they're
like,
Christina,
I'm all fucked up.
I need to get my shit together.
Like,
how do you,
uh,
how do you start with somebody?
It's different,
you know,
everybody's different.
But is there anything that people are
universally could benefit from Missouri?
Yeah.
The number one thing that where I start
with people is having them really look
at their relationship with themselves
because when they come they're like,
oh,
I'm fucked up,
or I need help.
They're relating to themselves as if
something's,
something's wrong with them and they're
being really hard on themselves and
they've kind of lost hope and lost
belief in themselves.
So the first thing is just like
acceptance,
accepting where you are because you
know,
I had,
I haven't liked everything that's
happened to me,
but one of the main raise I've been able
to move through it is because I stopped
fighting it.
Isn't that like in martial arts,
if a punch comes at you,
you're not supposed to resist it.
You're supposed to kind of move with it.
Yeah.
Move away from it or roll with it,
roll with it.
Right.
So that's like your teeth,
your teeth and taking on a job.
Exactly.
And in life we kind of do that where
like,
oh,
I don't want this break up,
I don't want this layoff.
We resist it,
we fight it.
And so it's like,
can we just get to acceptance of
playing?
Where are you are who you are and what's
happening right now?
Perspective and perspective.
Yeah.
And when you can get to that neutral
place,
that's when you can start doing the work
and that's when you can start doing
different things.
And then the second thing is I ask
people like,
do you believe you can shift?
Do you believe that you have the power
to make different choices and change and
you don't have to know how that's,
that's my job.
I'll help you with the how.
But you've got to believe you can
because if we don't believe it's
possible for us.
And it's really hard to make any kind of
change in our life.
Yeah,
that is,
that is giant.
But how does someone believe,
like how do you get someone to believe
that they can make change?
Like do they have to see evidence in
themselves?
Do you,
is there like do you recommend like
attempting things or tasks or hobbies
or.
Well,
a lot of times it's going back to a time
in your life where you did take a chance
or you did do something that was a
stretch in some way,
like everybody has times in their life
where they've done something they
weren't completely sure they could do
even if it's just a little thing and
everybody has that reference point they
can go back to,
but a lot of this joe,
like honestly a lot of it is taking a
leap of faith and I,
I've taken a lot of those and I've
wanted to know the answer and I've
wanted to know like 100 percent that
this would be guaranteed.
Like if I take this leap of faith,
everything will work out and they
haven't always been 100 percent
guarantees,
but it was in taking that leap and
taking that chance and having little
faith that things started showing up and
things started shifting and that's what
started to create the evidence.
And it's a tricky thing because I think
people want evidence before they make
change.
But you have to start making these
little changes to start having the
evidence show up.
I don't know if I answered your
question.
No,
that does make sense.
Um,
I,
I've often said that very difficult
tasks,
like a,
anything that's difficult that you do,
it gives you the confidence that you can
overcome adversity.
You can,
you can,
whether it's I'm a martial art thing or
something along those lines or marathon
running or anything.
When you do something like that,
these incremental changes happen where
you push yourself through things and
you,
especially if you can achieve a goal,
if you could set out to do something,
you achieve that goal.
Like,
I'm going to run a marathon by the end
of this year.
I don't know why I keep saying marathon,
but you know what I'm saying?
Doing things along those lines.
They can be motivating factors that they
can help push you.
They can be the engine that starts to
push things in a positive direction.
Can you start to believe in yourself and
you start to believe,
oh wow.
Like,
I can do this.
I can take this step.
You know,
I often tell people that show up or come
to workshop where I'm like,
just that fact that you're here is proof
that you believe you can change because
like you wouldn't have shown up if some
part of you was in,
you know,
kind of certain that you could
have you ever had someone come to you,
you're like,
I can't even help this dude.
The girl.
Not yet.
No.
Do you get mostly dudes or girls?
Well,
I only coach a few people now.
Um,
my retreats are mostly women.
My private clients both.
And then like courses and stuff.
How can we have retreats that are all
women?
Well,
I know,
I know I'm going to get,
I'm going to do one that will be both
men and women soon and it's like a
recipe for danger.
Too much depressed people hump it in the
woods or wherever we go.
The first one that everybody's
depressed.
Some people come just to grow and not
out in the woods
or out in the woods.
That's amazing.
No,
I like to do it in places like Bali and
Costa Rica jungle.
Oh my gosh.
I finally,
for people at this,
this might be able to some people,
so I,
whenever I go to anywhere tropical,
I get eaten alive,
like eaten alive no matter what other
people have three bites,
I'll have 400.
I finally figured out B one,
vitamin B,
one,
two.
It's totally stopped.
It really have to find it.
Like you can't take a b complex.
It's vitamin B One,
Huh?
And it's for some reason stops in
mosquitoes and bug bites.
Um,
why why B One?
I have no idea.
I just know it works for me.
Does something to change your smell?
I don't know.
It just worked.
It was my salvation.
I was so happy.
They don't bite you at all I little bit,
but again it went from being eaten alive
to just getting a few.
Did you ever try thermacell?
No.
What's that?
Thermo cell is a device that a lot of
people take when they go camping.
Things along those lines.
You,
um,
it's like a,
it looks like almost like a radio and it
has these little pads and these slide
these pads into this heating element.
And this very fine mist comes out of
this heating element.
You can put it on the ground near you
and the bugs won't come with an 18 foot
circle.
Yeah,
yeah.
They use it when you're hunting and
you're in the woods because if you're,
if you're in the woods,
like,
especially in Alaska or Alberta,
I don't know if you've ever been Alaska
in the summer.
The mosquitoes are insane because they
own their only alive for a month.
Oh,
so that is good at town,
like rabid Barbara,
Berrien mosquitoes like me and my friend
Ari went fishing in Alaska and it was so
crazy that you would get out of the car.
We pulled up to this,
uh,
this stream.
You get out of the car,
you open the door and then won't,
you're hit with a cloud of mosquitoes.
We jumped back in the car and shut the
door and we were in the car with like 50
mosquitoes were like,
what in the fuck is going on?
So then we're spraying ourselves all the
spray,
all these toxic chemicals.
Hell Dad found out about thermo sells.
Thermo cells just cleans it out.
Totally easy to travel with their.
Yeah,
they don't even.
They're really light.
It doesn't even smell.
I mean barely smells,
but bugs don't want to have anything to
do with it.
Mosquitoes don't want to have anything
to do with it without thermo cells like
hanging out in the woods,
like sitting in a spot.
It's almost unbearable unless you have
mosquito netting and you don't want to
wear like all that.
The mosquito bug spray stuff where your
skin is in Oregon,
you know all that stuff that you're
putting on your skin.
It is just not good.
It's not.
I was deet my first couple
of days on my last trip and I started
getting sick and I'm like,
I can't.
This is like,
what am I doing?
You're processing and with your liver,
from your skin,
it gets in your bloodstream.
Terrible.
Yeah.
I mean I'm sure there's probably some
nontoxic alternatives,
but they probably don't work there now,
so it worked for me.
Hey,
b one,
you hear it.
I've heard that before.
A friend of mine was telling me that
about Africa.
They went to Africa and they took a
bunch of b vitamins.
The B one in particular did it for me
find anything on that journey.
I found something that said that studies
are inconclusive,
but it may make mosquitoes.
Thank you.
Stink.
Good.
Perfect.
It's fine for me.
I wonder if it's like a vitamin that
makes people think you smell good.
People are mosquitoes people.
Yeah.
Because if bananas don't Eat Bananas for
Ms Dot Susan,
don't eat bananas.
That makes sense to it.
But I would think that like,
like this probably like weird smells
that you're not even sure you detect you
now.
Some people just give off a weird odor
to people.
Yes.
I mean not even like a,
maybe not older,
older,
but like they just feel weird,
you know,
they said that.
Um,
Chris Ryan,
my friend who's um,
um,
he,
he's an author,
he wrote a sex at dawn.
He's great,
super smart,
super smart guy.
He was telling me that there's certain
odors that human beings have and those
odors enable people to understand
whether or not they're genetically
compatible with each other and you know,
like they used to be when we were kids.
I used to always hear about couples
taking blood tests to make sure that
they could have babies together.
Yeah.
That was a thing.
They would,
they would make sure that they were
compatible and I don't even know if
there was.
It was real science behind it,
but they would take blood tests to find
out they were compatible.
That was like,
I remember it being like really common
to discuss.
I mean it was this is a the eighties or
the nineties or whatever the fuck.
It was the dark ages of science,
but for me it was that easy.
Right.
But not compatible.
Obviously personality wise and all the
other things that come into play.
But they were.
He.
Chris Ryan was saying that women can
smell a man's clothes,
like you could smell,
literally smell their clothes and they
would know whether or not they would be
attracted to that person based on the
smell that per person is getting.
Not Not like,
oh my God,
this guy stinks,
but like literally like you,
your body knows what's repulsive and
what's not repulsive in terms of
genetics,
based on someone's odor that they give
off on their clothes,
but what it didn't work is when they put
women on the pill,
so when they put women on the pill,
they were no longer able to
differentiate whether or not someone was
genetically compatible by smelling them
that it gave you.
It fogged up your,
your natural senses because I think when
you're on pill you don't actually
ovulate.
Right?
So you're not in the natural rhythm of
biology.
Yeah,
I think there's a natural feeling that
women have when they're around a guy
that they would breed with or a guy they
wouldn't breed with like,
okay,
gotTa go,
you know,
like that.
And that is probably a good thing.
And the people that are on the pill
might be making like really shitty
genetic choices,
like literally genetic choices.
Ah,
you can blame your last bad ex boyfriend
on being on the pill.
You could smell them accurately.
I really think you can.
I mean,
it totally makes sense.
I probably.
Chris has probably listening right now
go and you fucked it up.
I probably did,
but I think there's probably something
to instinctual reactions to people.
I mean,
have you ever met someone who,
for whatever reason,
I just don't want to be around this
person and then you find out years later
that that person is fucking crazy or
this or that.
There's,
I think people give off in detectable in
terms of like what we classify as
smells,
but maybe these pheromones have some
sort of a weird reaction to your birth
control pills affects women's taste in
men.
Bam.
Wow.
How synthetic hormones changed desires
and women and their choice of a mate
intimate.
Yeah,
totally.
Makes Sense.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Well it just makes sense.
I mean,
it just can't be.
Nor your body must be so confused.
Like this pitch is pregnant all the
time.
I know.
That's what it thinks.
Your body thinks you're pregnant all the
time now.
That's the pill scares me too.
Just synthetic hormones pumping through
your system.
Yeah.
Camp can't be all that good to never get
off,
but a lot of women never get off it
right there on it forever.
Yep.
Yeah.
I don't like it.
It makes my hair oily when I'm off at.
Yup.
Here's stuff like that.
There's other ways to balance your
hormones.
You know,
I'm not a hormone specialist,
but why does hormones make a girl's hair
oily?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
How do we get on the subject?
Smells.
Retreats.
You don't take dudes.
Dudes on retreats.
Yeah.
I would think they're like getting a
bunch of people that are trying to get
their life together and then having them
all together.
Male and female.
Do you run into these weird issues?
Were
anything that really just trying to hook
up?
Yeah,
exactly.
You can get really distracted and you
can get,
like if there's some kind of attraction,
you can forget what you're there for and
get obsessed with someone and,
and it can kind of throw off the thing
and there's something too about,
you know,
women coming together with women and men
coming together with men that I think is
important.
And I think kind of back to that tribal
conversation we need,
I got a lot of women including myself,
have beef with other women,
you know,
and they don't like being around just a
bunch of other women.
Like there's competition that comes up
and Oh,
well I used to because I was scared of
other women because I had all that stuff
happen.
I didn't really trust it.
Um,
and so when you get a group of women
together,
a lot of times there is that like
comparison and judgment and I can't
trust into that.
And so it's important for women,
I think to gather together and kind of
do work separately from when there's men
there because there's something that is
very healing just in that.
And then,
you know,
it just,
there's a level of vulnerability that's
possible when there aren't men.
They're not to say that you can't be
vulnerable with men there,
but it's just a different dynamic.
And I think the same goes for men,
like I know men who do men's groups and
men's work and there's great value in
that and that's important.
And I think one of the problems I see a
lot in intimate relationships is that in
a heterosexual relationship is that you
expect this one person to be your
everything and you're not.
You don't have a tribe and you don't
have a community,
you don't have friends of the opposite
sex in the same sex that are fulfilling
kind of these needs that we all have.
We just project like this.
My one person has to be my everything,
my soul mate.
And so,
you know,
having your community,
whatever it may be,
and having different friends I think is
super,
super important to having a healthy
relationship.
Yeah,
having friends period is super
important.
There is something that I tweeted today
that I was reading about,
um,
they were talking about the role that
genetics and family have in creating a
personality and how much of an impact
your peers have and they think that your
peers and the friends you choose have a
bigger impact than anything in your
life.
And it was really fascinating.
I,
I tweeted this morning on it,
but it's,
it's one of those articles where you
read it and you go,
oh,
that completely makes sense.
Researcher argues that peers are much
more important than parents,
that psychologists underestimate the
power of genetics and that we have a lot
to learn from Asian classrooms.
Interesting.
Yeah.
What about it?
What about Asian classrooms to go down
and scroll?
Forgot what that was about.
I don't know,
probably too long of an article to
really get into it,
but um,
would have to read it.
But peers in general,
I think I'm choosing likeminded folks
and choosing people that are on a good
path.
They,
it,
it helps support you and it supports
them and you feed off of each other.
And when the tribe does well,
you do well.
Exactly.
This is very,
very critical and people,
everybody wants to be the person that's
accomplishing things.
Everybody wants to be the one that's out
there.
Go get knit and fuck the world's all
about me.
But if you do that,
you like,
you're gonna,
you're gonna mess up the whole happiness
thing.
Like the happiness thing comes with all
the people that you're around having a
good time.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
And then it's just like,
it's endless.
You have to keep upping the ante.
And I think what we want more than
anything is connection.
Connection.
We want love,
we want to feel like we belong to.
So I think belonging is a huge,
huge,
huge thing.
And I think as adults we think we belong
by,
you know,
achieving things.
But really it's finding those people
that you can just be yourself
with and to have that tribe and also let
go of the people that are bringing you
down.
Like I've outgrown some people in my
life and some friends.
Not that I'm better than,
but I'm just on like a different,
different path and a different route and
it's important I think to kind of know
like who's the sort of dead weight and
your life and what are some friendships
that might have reached their expiration
date that you know,
like,
I love you,
that's been great,
but you know,
and a lot of those friendships,
like you're not helping them either.
No.
Matter of fact,
sometimes when someone cuts you loose,
you go,
wow,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
They don't need to look at myself.
Right.
I mean sometimes when you enable a
friend,
you're not only,
you're not doing yourself any good,
you're not doing them any good either.
Exactly.
That was a big Aha for me when my fiance
broke up with me because I very much
wanted to be the victim in that,
but I had to look at,
Gosh,
what did I like?
What did I do?
Because everybody's like,
oh,
he's such a jerk,
but I really had to look at how was I
showing up in that relationship that was
impacting his decision because he wasn't
a bad guy.
Like he wasn't just a jerk who decided,
you know,
I'm going to break up with this girl.
Like there were ways I was showing up
that were like made him make the
decision that he makes.
So I think in any of those situations,
friendship or relationship,
you know,
you don't,
you don't want to go too far.
The other extreme and be like,
oh my gosh,
I'm a loser and think it's all your
fault.
But it's important to look at,
Geez,
what's my part in this?
You know,
what's my responsibility?
Because I played a role in this whole
thing.
Yeah,
I mean there's no one way street when it
comes to relationship and if you're in a
relationship with a bad person,
like why?
Why did you get in that in the first
place?
You know,
if they did trick you,
you know,
what did you do when you realized it was
a trick?
Did you stick around and try to fix it?
Yeah,
I think that's a really good question
because I mean how many people do you
know that are in bad relationships?
Continue talking about it but don't,
aren't doing anything about it.
Like they're brutal.
They're not leaving it and if people are
brutal are because there's just like
lie,
but a lot of times it's because it's
familiar and it's date.
What there's somebody said,
you know,
you get the love you think you deserve
and it may be easy for us looking
outside going,
oh my gosh,
it's so easy.
You should just like leave this
relationship.
But a lot of times the person like
doesn't think they can do better.
Or maybe this is like playing out some
dynamic they had with their parent or
you know,
you sort of need to understand why
you're in it before you can actually
make the choice to get out of it.
By the way,
there's a lot of delusional people out
there that are like,
I deserve a lot more than I'm getting.
That's true.
That's not really there.
What do you do when someone comes to you
with unrealistic expectations or they
don't want to see themselves like you
know,
you'd,
you'd tell them what they need to do or
what they should consider and they argue
with you about it.
Well,
I just really ask like,
is what you're doing working like is
your way working?
You can show me your ways working then.
Great.
My weight is fine.
This is fucking other people.
Everybody else.
Everybody else is all messed up.
I'm good.
God Damn it.
Yeah.
I need you to coach everyone else.
I know.
Yeah.
If we could just change other people.
It's everybody else's fault.
Yup.
Do you ever have to tell people you're
not going to work with them?
I've had one person I had to tell that
to.
Yup.
Just one and it was,
you know,
I think it was,
it was just not a good fit and she just
wasn't ready.
Willing.
The super committed to her story and
sort of wanted me just to cuddle it,
which I wasn't willing to do.
Yeah.
Sometimes people just want someone to
that.
That's what I've always wondered about
therapy.
Like I have friends that have been to
therapy,
I'm like,
okay,
well what do you do when you go there?
You talk about your problems and one
happens while they give you advice and
then what happens?
You don't do shit.
You know,
like there's a lot of people that just
want to go somewhere and once a month to
listen to them talk.
Right?
Right.
They'll go three,
four times a week and they're still
fucked up.
I'm like,
well,
that isn't working.
Yeah,
it doesn't.
And I think my intention always is to
really give people the tools,
not just advice and really help them
heal really get.
I've had amazing teachers have been
really,
really lucky and they've really taught.
They haven't just given me advice,
they haven't just given me motivation.
They've really given me tools to heal
and change and that's,
that's what I try to do in my work with
people is show them that it that a as
possible and they can do it and give
them the tools to do it because that's
what that's going to last longer than
any kind of like
pep talk.
It was funny.
We were talking before the podcast
started about going to a seminar and
someone asking how many men here feel
vulnerable?
And like no one's putting their hand up.
How many women here feel vulnerable?
All the hands went up,
all the hands went up and I mean,
part of it I think is a little
delusional because I think a lot of men
are way more vulnerable than they really
think they are.
But also there's just a different thing
going through live.
I mean there's that expression,
the fairer sex or.
But being a female,
being a woman means you are physically
different.
Yup.
Your roundup,
a bunch of people that most of them
could beat you up.
Yep.
You know,
that's,
it's a different way to walk through the
world.
That vulnerability though is that
creates another level of anxiety,
right?
Like walking down a dark street,
you see someone and it's a man and he's
walking down a dark street to like,
Oh,
you know,
yeah.
Um,
it's,
it's scary and it's something that,
you know,
I,
as a woman,
like I'm always aware of it.
Not always,
but a lot of the time,
you know,
cause I,
I know that like,
like you said,
I could get beaten up like it's between
me and a man.
He's probably gonna win.
I mean I'm pretty strong but
not that strong and I live.
I think what's also beautiful about
women and just the feminine general is
that vulnerability.
But because like at sometimes as it
feels safe,
I think that's why a lot of women like
kind of have a protective armor and are
guarded and sometimes more and they're
like masculine energy in the world is
because on some level we feel like we
have to,
we have to like protect ourselves and
whereas that,
that vulnerability really is the thing
that makes us women in so many ways not.
And I think we confuse vulnerability
with weakness because vulnerability to
me is being open,
being available,
being um,
soft but not weak.
Weakness to me is more about kind of
going into the victimy and going into
that poor pitiful me and the feeling
sorry for and on all of those kinds of
things.
I think there's beautiful power and
vulnerability,
but when we're talking about just
physical strength,
yeah,
I mean for the most part,
men have the advantage on that one.
It's just we need all the pieces,
right?
You need the whole spectrum of human
beings and it.
I mean,
especially in terms of,
you know,
the traditional way of looking at
things.
You know,
masculine men are attracted to feminine
women and Feminine.
Women are attracted to masculine men and
we both need each other,
but a lot of times,
especially when you're dealing with
damaged folks,
you're dealing with a man who has a
vulnerable woman in the man's all fucked
up,
so he takes it out on the vulnerable
woman and the vulnerable woman is like
under the,
you know,
the,
the pressure of the relationship or the
suppression of being connected to this
man,
and so you kind of dealing with the same
dynamic that you were dealing with when
you were in school or someone's bullying
you and you get it in this relationship.
Then instead of someone appreciating you
for the difference in the softness
versus the of the Yin and the Yang,
now you have someone who is exploiting
that and you see it with women too and
they see it with like aggressive women
and weak men.
That is,
to me,
one of the saddest things I ever see is
when you find the aggressive women and
the weak man cut.
Probably because I'm terrified of it
ever been me.
You know,
I don't think it will be,
but I mean if it was,
you know,
nobody wants that.
Nobody wants a woman who's yelling at
you and andy goes,
woohoo.
That happens a lot,
a lot,
a lot.
It's kind of crazy to me because,
you know,
I see women emasculate men quite often,
not maybe on like a huge scale to the
degree you're talking about,
but just like the little comments,
like I'll be out with a couple and the
woman will say something and it's,
it's kind of emasculating.
If the roles were reversed and the guy
said something like that to the woman,
I don't know if it would go over,
you know,
guys just kinda take it
on sometimes and then when I see that
I'm like,
a lot of men feel emasculated by society
in general,
just by the roles that they play in the
office and the,
just the,
the,
the physical act of going through life,
this civilized world and also constantly
needing people's affirmation,
needing people's acceptance and,
and you,
you sort of become what people want you
to be,
even if that's not what you want.
You get in these relationships and you
see it all the time where a guy sort of
accept a little bit and then they accept
more and then they don't want to mess
up.
And then I have a bunch of friends that
have like really domineering,
overbearing wives or girlfriends.
And it's weird.
It's weird to be around them.
Like,
dude,
you know,
you can leave.
Like,
he just like,
this is just a person.
Why do you think they don't?
Because they're scared.
They're scared and it becomes the thing.
You know,
that's,
that's the thing,
this is the thing,
or go out of the fucking wife,
we're going to go home to the wife,
you know,
and it's,
it's,
it's very strange.
It's very strange when you have someone
in your life that's essentially like a
parole officer,
so many life that gets to tell you what
to do and you're not allowed to do
certain things.
You're not allowed to watch certain
things or certain things and they
control you and they own.
You mean this,
this,
and I think a lot of these people that
are doing that,
much like the girl who bullied you or
any,
anybody who does that to someone,
they,
they do it out of,
out of fear.
They do that to insecurity and they also
do it out of this bizarre instinct
because they can.
I state this girl,
she wasn't a bad person but she used to
like to fight and I don't.
I do not.
I do not like to.
I don't like that kind of conflict.
I don't like,
like interrelationship conflict.
I don't do.
I don't like it.
I won't fight and argue.
I just rather leave.
I'm like all into I'm into discussing
things,
but when people start yelling and get
crazy,
I'm like,
fuck this.
I grew up.
I grew up around domestic violence too.
I grew up with a,
so I saw it when I was a kid.
I just,
I'm not interested and so we broke up,
but we stayed friends and then years
later we went out to coffee and like,
how's everything?
What's going on?
I'm living with this guy.
It's not going good.
I'm like,
why?
She's like,
she's telling me how she yells at this
guy and she can't help it.
She's like,
I can't help it.
I just fucking yell at him and he
doesn't do anything.
He just takes it and she's like,
he takes it.
I just want to fucking smash him.
She's like,
I just can't.
She goes,
I don't want to yell at them,
but I can't help doing it.
And then when he's gone,
I'm like,
why the fuck did I do that?
And she had this weird,
almost like a natural impulse to
dominate this guy.
Like if you ever seen two dogs,
one dog has the upper hand on the on the
dog and he'll go near the dog and the
other dog and that's just,
that's just their world.
That's just their world.
The other dog never gets a chance and
sometimes it's not even a size based
thing or they might be the exact same
size dog,
just one dog just decides the bitch and
the other one's the dominator and that's
just how it goes.
While she was in this position with this
guy where she just had this compelling
desire to fucking yell at them.
And I go,
well,
what are you yelling at him for?
She's like,
anything,
everything.
She goes,
I just,
I just fucking.
I want him to tell me to shut the fuck
up.
Yeah.
She wanted him to out manner.
But isn't that crazy?
Like what a bizarre instinct to like to,
to push.
Like she was frustrated at herself.
She was frustrated at him,
but it's almost like she was compelled,
like she's being drawn to the great
magnet,
you know?
It's like,
oh,
I'm going to scream at them.
Right.
Well it's interesting like how we
project onto other people,
you know,
like whatever.
Some of that was going on inside of her
that was like creating that dynamic in
him and then she could have left at any
time.
It was like she was so trying to get a
reaction out of him honestly to probably
see if he cared.
Like she probably equated.
Alright well him taking it means he
doesn't care.
So how much can I push?
How much can I push,
how can I match,
can I push so that I can see that he,
he'll react enough because that means.
Do you think that's what it is that she
didn't think he cares or do you think
she just thinks he's weak and it's just
frustrating to her that he's weak?
Well,
if it was just that,
I think she would have left a lot
earlier.
There was something she wanted,
like we don't keep doing it over and
over and over again unless there's
something more attached to getting.
Like,
you know,
when we're just went and we're like,
Oh man,
this is stupid.
We,
we get out of there.
But when we find ourselves in situations
where it's like it's happening over and
over and over again and tend to get
frustrated but we're not leaving.
There's something we're attached to
trying to get from our behavior.
So there was something she wanted in
that,
there was something in it for her,
although I should have been out there a
lot sooner.
I wonder.
It was also she was trying to do the
acting thing and she was constantly
frustrated.
She was constantly just taking it out
and everything.
Well that it was,
it would be really interesting.
Like I'd watch these like almost sort of
manic things.
Like there would be these moments where
she would be preparing for an audition
and she'd be hopeful yet nervous.
There was a lot of anxiety and there was
all this,
here's the thing and it's going to go
and hopefully if this happens,
this guy's connected to this and that's
going to happen with that.
And then boom,
it didn't happen.
And so there's this massive let down,
there's a cigarette smoking and
depression and you know,
all this angst and I got the fuck out of
there.
But this dude got in there like,
and he caught me,
he caught,
you know,
the second wave of angst when I met her.
She was just moving here and so she
wasn't completely bewildered by the
experience in the machine yet.
Yeah.
And it's also,
I think for some people choosing things
that you do for a living that are
healthy for you,
I think there's a lot of people that get
involved in careers that require too
much of their time.
You don't really want to do it,
but you get caught up in it.
Whether it's being a lawyer,
being a doctor,
or being something that has a
prestigious title when you feel like
there's something great tech,
but really in the back of your mind,
there's something else that you probably
be way happier doing.
I mean,
that was me.
I was going after it for the wrong
reasons.
What do you want to do though?
If you weren't doing a life coach,
I know you enjoy doing what you're
doing,
but you have like if somehow or another
you were independently wealthy and you
didn't have to coach all these crazy
people.
Not that they're crazy,
but some of them will probably do it.
I mean like I,
you know,
this,
I,
I love people and I love personal
development.
Even if I had all the money in the
world,
I still speak.
I'd still do my podcasts.
I'd still do retreats.
I,
I love it.
Like I love the human experience.
I love being there for that moment where
someone has a major insight where they
connect dots and it's like Whoa,
a massive perspective shift and like all
of a sudden they start to kind of move a
different direction.
It's,
I can't imagine doing anything else.
I mean if I could sing,
if I had any kind of music ability,
I think it'd be awesome to be a rock
star.
Like just to have that rush,
but literally I have no musical ability
whatsoever other than listening to it.
I'm just do not have it.
Well that's great.
So you found your thing now how often is
it when you talk to be,
but when you're trying to coach them and
help them and you realize like,
man,
you got to do something else.
Like is that A.
is that a factor?
Because I would think that see the thing
about careers is not only is it eight
hours of your time,
but it also kind of defines you,
so every day you're defined by whatever
you do and oftentimes,
like we were talking about like men in
these workplace environments,
there's sort of like,
they're boxed into this predetermined
pattern or behavior that's expected from
them.
You know,
they have shoes with tassels on them and
ties and they have to talk business talk
and it's like you fall into these weird
patterns and you lose a lot of your
individuality inside those patterns
because office life and you know,
human resources demand certain things of
you.
Like there's a certain your personality,
like when you're in an office
environment,
anytime you're in the corporate world,
your personality is stuffed into this
form.
Whatever that form is,
whatever that mold is,
the mold of being a business person.
You know,
you know you're a woman.
You're a businesswoman.
You want to be respected and want to use
the right word to say the right things
and you know,
and,
and talk the right lingo.
But the like a lot of times people are
left wondering who the fuck am I?
Right,
right,
right.
They just get totally lost in a role.
Yeah.
And I do like,
I go do a lot of corporate speaking and
I have a lot of people come up to me
afterwards and they're just like,
oh my gosh,
like I'm.
Because I talk about,
you know,
how we lose ourselves in these roles and
how like a lot of times our adult life
becomes sort of just this like checklist
follow
Truman show.
Like one thing after the other just like
follow this structure that was set out
for us.
We never checked in and said,
do I want this?
Like,
do I even want this?
You know.
And so to answer your question,
yes,
a lot of times when people come or I'm
working with people,
it is like looking at like,
is this,
is this career right for you?
Is this relationship right for you?
Like what have you created in your life
that just doesn't fit where you are,
but you're in it because you're scared
to make the change.
And,
and also,
you know,
some people really can be happy in
corporate America,
like some people
she works for them.
I,
um,
I really believe that the vast majority
of people that are living the American
dream,
living that life during that nine to
five,
the vast majority of them are fucking
horrific.
Horrifically miserable.
Yeah.
I really do believe that.
I think it's,
it's so defining and it's so.
It's so contrary to the human spirit.
Right?
Right.
But I think most people don't want to
believe that.
They don't want to believe that it's
possible that everybody's doing
something wrong.
Right.
And they don't believe they can change
it then.
Yeah.
There's no other option.
I don't know what else to do,
especially if they have a mortgage and a
spouse and kids,
student loans,
all that stuff.
Yeah.
It's really intimidating to go,
oh gosh,
how do I,
how do I change this?
I think you have to start small.
I think you have to start with,
okay,
I don't have to quit my job tomorrow,
but what are some things in my life I
can start doing that made me feel alive
again?
Like,
is it a hobby,
is it like training for a marathon?
Is it what is going to start making me
feel like,
you know,
I'm creative and I matter and I'm more
than just this role as husband,
wife,
mother,
father,
corporate executive,
whatever it is.
So I think that's a good place to start
is something small you can do to make
you feel alive again because anybody has
access to that,
right?
You don't have to leave your job to
start creating some things in your life
that can start to shift things and then
like we were talking about then it's
like the gradual change,
you know,
because I don't think it's possible for
most people just to quit their job
tomorrow.
They don't think it's possible.
Right.
Almost knowing exactly what and,
and not everybody's meant to be an
entrepreneur either and do their own
thing,
but there are always things we can do in
our life to mix it up a little bit and
even just show up differently in our
job.
Yeah.
I just think that for a huge amount of
people,
the amount of time that's required of
them.
Yeah.
Because of their job is so overwhelming
because most people,
let's be honest or not really just
working nine to five,
particularly most men,
there's a tremendous amount of overtime
involvement.
Yes.
I was looking at some thing that was
talking about.
It was an article on the wage gap
difference in what would it really is
about.
And one of the things that was about was
the amount of the difference in the
amount of hours that men work and in
their ambition to try to climb up the
corporate ladder.
And you look at the numbers that people
work and it's terrifying.
There's no lie.
If you're working 60 hours a week,
you don't have a life.
There's nothing left.
If I worked here,
um,
I'll do a podcast or three hours and
I'll do a bunch of other stuff and you
know,
I'm trying to fit in things in my day
and I have a pretty loose schedule.
I mean,
I do a lot of things,
but it's pretty loose.
You know,
like today I did UFC stuff for a couple
hours this morning and then I come here
for a few hours.
Then I got to work out.
Then it will tell some jokes,
but there's a lot of movement in there.
There's a lot of times where I can get
shit done.
Yeah.
Some people don't have any of that.
It have nothing.
So what do you think was like that made
you different,
like back in the day where you could
have done that path of the corporate
route?
Why did you make different choices?
It's a good question.
I don't know.
Probably.
I mean I never felt like I could.
I never felt like I could have a regular
job like I.
from the time I got out of high school,
I never had a full time job.
I had a bunch of part time jobs.
I did some full time jobs,
were construction companies and stuff,
but it didn't last.
I would do them for like a month or a
couple of weeks and I was like,
fuck this,
like whatever it is about.
And it was all.
It was the main source
of all my problems in high school.
All my problems in high school is I was
not willing to do things I didn't want
to do,
so I would barely get by through high
school.
I go take tests.
They would register intelligence or
measure intelligence.
That'd be great.
Everything's fine,
but I would take actual test based on
what I was supposed to be studying and I
fucking barely paid attention.
I mean I squoze through high school with
like a c average in most things.
I barely got by and even when I was
going to college I was only going to
college.
I went to Boston University and our
umass rather in Boston and the only
reason why I went is because I didn't
want anybody to think I was a loser.
So I was taking classes at Umass and
was.
It was and I was teaching taekwondo at
Boston University,
which is a really good school and I was
looking at all these people that were
preparing for life and to me it was
like,
you're going to go get eaten by
alligators or something.
And I was like,
what are you going to do?
You're going to go get a job.
You're going to be working nine to five
for whatever,
whatever fucked up thing that was wrong
in my head.
I would way rather get up in the morning
and deliver newspapers for three hours a
day or drive limos at night.
I.
I had a really unstable childhood,
so in my mind,
anything that you were locked down to
was death.
It was prison and I,
whatever malfunction of my brain,
I figured out a way to make it work for
me.
Survival skill.
Yeah,
in some way,
but also a lack of like I'm not very
disciplined.
It looks like I'm disciplined on the
outside.
I'm not disciplined at all.
I'm obsessed.
I get obsessed with things whether I'm
disciplined with in certain aspects like
with exercise and I do it when I don't
want to do it.
I forced myself to practice and I forced
myself to write.
I forced myself to do things,
but more of it's more of an obsession
thing.
Like I get obsessed with either goals or
tasks or things or puzzles or games.
I got a real problem,
like there's something wrong with me.
Well why do you say that?
As a field draining
no,
because like I'll play pool for 12 hours
in a row,
like I'll,
I'll get obsessed with playing pool and
then I think I'm going to be the world
champion.
I'm going to practice 12 hours a day for
the rest of my life.
I mean I,
I,
I'm a sick person.
Like whatever happened to me when I was
young,
like whatever weirdness in involved in
it.
I figured out a way to manage it,
but it can get away from me.
It's gotten away from me before I played
video games,
like eight,
10 hours a day.
It can get away.
I got have to manage whatever craziness
that makes me like focus on things.
Yeah.
I see it in my kids.
Especially my middle daughter,
she's,
she gets obsessed with things and I'm
like,
wow,
this is crazy.
It's like a genetic thing.
It's like watching a little female,
me and a lot of ways,
you know,
like she read all eight Harry Potter
books in a matter of a couple of months.
She just,
she just gets into stuff and then you've
got to go,
Hey,
shut the light out.
You got to go to bed one more chapter
like,
come on,
you got to stop.
It's been um,
it's not like she's seen it in me and
she's mirroring it because it's her own
little weirdness,
you know,
but I think it's obviously she's got a
healthier environment than I grew up in,
so it's not like a,
a matter of plug not ever not ever
wanting to be connected to anything
permanent because nothing is permanent.
I mean that was part of,
I think with the lessons from my
childhood.
Like no one's here to help you.
Not As,
don't get locked in any fucking job,
don't get locked in and you get ready to
move in anytime,
you know.
And embracing moving.
Like to this day I'll be,
I'll be like,
I gotta get the fuck out of La.
Like everything's here.
I have to do everything here.
The comedy is here,
my family's here.
My kids go to school here.
All my friends live here,
but I'm like,
fuck this.
I'm going to the mountains.
I gotta get Outta here.
Like I have this like no mad shit in me
that I'm like constantly trying to,
um,
to manage.
So
as much as people like to take credit
for a certain amount of success,
like I can tell you all the different
things that I did that led to me being
successful at things.
But almost it's like the function of a
mental issue,
like a big,
a lot of it is a function of learning
how to manage a brain that doesn't work
like everybody else's brain.
That's so I think common for a lot of
successful people especially.
And the differences.
You're aware of how it works and you've
learned how to manage it,
but that you know,
that obsessive thing in so many ways it
has made you,
it has gotten you a certain degree of
success and all of those things,
survival skills,
compensatory strategies,
whatever they are,
they have their positives,
they have ways that they really help us.
But then they have the ways that kind of
torture us and a lot of ways.
And I think
growth is really about understanding
what are the ways that this isn't doing
me any good and how can I be mindful of
it.
And also like,
you know,
how,
how do I know now that like that now is
not then like how do I stop being
activated by old experiences in my past
and just have peace for where I am now
and take those gifts from the obsession
that's made you successful but not have
the parts that kind of torture you at
the same.
Well,
I don't feel tortured.
Um,
so I think in some ways have achieved
some sort of a victory over my whatever
mental issues that I have.
But I can't do nothing.
Right.
That's the reason why I have three jobs.
I can't do that if I do.
And I have three jobs and a fucking ton
of obsessions outside of those jobs.
Martial arts,
archery or reading and writing and all
sorts of other stuff on top of
podcasting,
doing the commentary for the UFC,
doing standup comedy.
Like that's the only way I'm,
I feel even.
Yeah.
And I can't have one thing that I count
on either.
If I had,
if I only had standup comedy or only had
the UFC.
If there's only one thing or only had
podcasting,
I'd be like,
this is my.
I got it.
I would want to quit.
I was like,
I don't want to do this anymore.
This is my fucking thing.
I'm just going to be trapped doing this
thing.
Talking into a fucking microphone out
into space for the rest of my life.
I got to go to fucking.
I don't even want to hear myself
anymore.
I've got to quit.
No.
So whatever weird malfunction my brains
had.
I've figured out a way over all the
years of my life to,
to manage it,
but a lot of his physical to managing my
brain,
a lot of it requires intense exercise.
Like when I,
when I intensely exercise,
then I can like,
oh alright,
it's gonna be all right,
it's going to be cool.
But if I don't,
it's like it's all built up.
And then there's,
it's hard to enjoy things.
It's hard to just chill.
Like I can't chill unless I earn it.
It gets a,
it's probably a malfunction,
but it's the illusion is that it's not
the illusion is that it's a discipline
and then it's all,
it's all choices,
but that's really not the case.
Maybe it's just you and how you operate
your operating system.
Are You coaching me now?
So what's going on here?
Does that feel like I am?
Yeah,
maybe it is me.
I mean,
I think people,
and that's not a bad thing.
I think that they're back to the
acceptance thing.
There's a lot of ways I think we're
supposed to be and we look at other
people and how they do their life or
whatever and we think that because we're
acting this way,
something must be wrong with us,
but a lot of times there is not.
This is just the way you operate.
You don't want to.
And that's the thing is interesting is
um,
when I was a kid I was a not very
confident and also didn't like to,
to people get anxiety again,
anxiety.
If I had a talk and I get anxiety,
if I had to like talk to a bank teller,
like if I had to wait in line to go to
the bank teller,
I'd start freaking out like on my way to
the bank teller and like if you talked
to like people who knew me from high
school and they'll go,
uh,
did you ever think that Joe is going to
be a comedian?
They be like,
no,
like no fucking way.
That guy was at funny,
like they didn't.
I figured out a way to be more relaxed
socially and it wasn't an easy process
at all.
It took forever to the point where now
I'm extremely relaxed socially.
Like now I can talk to anybody.
Like I don't.
I love one of the things I love about
doing podcasts.
I like just having conversations with
people.
Yeah,
I will.
I want to know,
like you're another organism.
You're another person.
I want to know what's going on in your
head.
I don't understand your life.
I wanna I wanna own a.
try to see what connections you've made,
what,
what definitions you've fallen on,
you know,
what you know,
how you've defined this world,
how you've,
how you've categorized things and how
you're managing it.
How are you,
how are you maneuvering through it?
I'm fascinated by that.
I'm fascinated by the thoughts that
people carry around inside their heads.
Yeah,
me too.
I love it.
And whether or not they're empowering or
whether or not you're a woe is me type
person,
you know,
and one of the puzzle pieces that have
led to where you are and I love that
you're sharing this because I think a
lot of people can see you and see your
success in everything that you have and
thank you were always like this and then
it's just been easy because it's this,
you know,
you're always like this,
but to know you had that background and
you had the social anxiety and this is
like such a stretch.
I think it's really inspiring because it
gives people.
It's like,
oh you,
you can't.
You can no longer argue that,
you know,
you're just born a certain way.
And like,
that's just the way you are,
like your proof that you actually can
change and you can't get over things and
you can create things that you know,
you probably didn't think were possible
when you were 10 or however old you were
when you were going through all that
stuff.
Yeah,
I think
people have different starting points
and now it's like I was saying that if
you want to climb Mount Everest,
good luck.
If you're starting from Santa Monica,
you got to fucking walk all the way to
Tibet.
It's going to take a long ass time.
Ocean is going to be hard to get across.
But if you're at the base of Tibet,
if that's what you live,
it's or the base of the Himalayas,
it's way easier to climb that thing.
You know,
it's still not easy,
but it's easier.
And I think there's a lot of people that
start,
you know,
in the a metaphoric Santa Monica would
their life,
they're really far away from their goal.
It doesn't mean it's not possible,
but it means there's a bunch of steps,
whether they're conscious or unconscious
that you're going to have to make in
order to get to a position.
And I still remember fucking freaking
out going to a bank teller or used to
having all the time.
I just didn't want to talk to people.
I was just in my own head and I was
super insecure and I just could barely
get through shit,
you know,
what changed it,
just doing it over and over again.
Martial arts was a big thing.
The martial arts is the first thing that
I ever did where I was good at it or I
didn't feel like a loser.
It was like I'd done.
I was pretty good at art and uh,
yes.
Yeah.
And I wanted to be a comic book
illustrator and that was like a big
focus in my life when I was younger.
But um,
I mean,
and I and I definitely took some sort of
identity in the fact that I was good at
that.
I liked the fact that people would say I
was good at it and made me feel good,
but it was different than martial arts
because with martial arts,
um,
it was the first thing that I did where
I felt like I could really be
exceptional.
Like it could be really good,
like in an hour,
realized that
first of all I was gifted physically and
then also this crazy brain of mine,
if I could point it to something,
like I would work out at 3:00 in the
morning because I knew nobody else
would.
I knew they weren't there,
so I had keys to the gym.
So,
uh,
because I was teaching,
so I would go there,
I'd wake up and I would drive down to
the gym and I opened it up in the middle
of the night and put in a workout
because I knew that no one else was
doing that.
I knew they weren't there and I knew,
I felt like it gave me an this.
Well,
yeah,
an edge.
But it also,
I felt like there was,
I was getting ahead of them,
you know,
like,
like it was,
it was some sort of a crazy race.
So for between the age of 15 and 21,
I was just completely obsessed with
fighting and that's all I did.
I just,
I didn't,
I didn't know.
I probably barely knew who was
president.
I didn't know a goddamn thing about the
world.
I wasn't reading shit unless it was like
some Samurai book on philosophy and
combat.
Like that was all I was obsessed with
and that's when I was also a gun and
they were Ah,
anthony robins somewhere around that
too.
But I was interested in like things that
would give me an edge,
personal development stuff that would
give me an edge and then through doing
martial arts and then also through
teaching,
I think that was a big one was teaching
classes.
And then teaching at bu was big too
because when I was teaching at Boston
University,
I was teaching an actual class.
Are you teaching taekwondo window?
That was at that time I was a.
I'd won the US Open.
I'd won a bunch of different tournaments
and I was,
I was doing really well as a,
as a fighter,
as a martial arts competitor.
So,
um,
they had uh,
a taekwondo program at Bu and I was
teaching it and I would have to address
a whole class,
but I would address all classes,
something that was really good at,
like I knew I could demonstrate them to
them,
some movements and stuff like that.
It shows some things.
I'd asked someone to hold something and
I'd kick it or something like that and
they'd be like,
Holy Shit.
And then they would listen.
Like I could get,
I could,
I was confident in what I was saying
there.
And it was like the only time in my life
that I can remember being confident in
telling people something.
It was like I would describe how you do
it,
this is how you do it and I'll show you
how to do it here,
but this is how it needs to be done.
And this is why.
And this is what happens when you do it.
And this is what's involved in the
mechanisms of your body.
And,
and so that,
that gave me the first,
that was the first feeling that I got
were there,
was I,
I knew that there was like a light at
the end of the tunnel or at least I
knew,
well at least this now I don't feel like
a loser anymore.
Yeah,
yeah.
It gave you something to like,
like you said,
be exceptional at.
And I think that's what gives us
confidence is feeling like we've
somewhat mastered something like
somewhat really could understand
something well enough to teach it.
Yes.
And without that we're just chasing it I
think for and trying to get it through
little things we do.
And I think that's why a lot of people
like go from career to career,
job to job or whatever.
Trying to find that little bit of
instead of sticking with something and
like really focusing in on really
studying it.
And that's where I think the obsession
actually served in a lot of ways.
I think for sure.
This is also an expression that I love
to use that martial arts are a vehicle
for developing your human potential
because.
Because it's so difficult and it's so
terrifying,
and then the idea of competing and in
the physical consequences are so
devastating.
If you get hit that you are,
you can't,
you can't have asset,
you can't slack off,
you have to.
You have to really pursue this thing
with an insanity,
like an incredible intensity and then
through that you realize like,
oh,
I could do that.
And then from doing that you kind of
realized,
well,
what if I apply that to writing a book
or doing that or learning how to do
something else,
or for me it was standup comedy.
Wow.
That seat,
standup comedy seems just terrifying to
me.
Karen
terrifying is working in a fucking
office wearing tassels,
shiny shoes.
That's very true.
Stupid thing.
Socks are too.
Yeah.
That was terrifying for me to.
Oh God.
I remember like Sunday nights I would
just get knots in my stomach just like,
oh,
do I have to go and be in awful staff
meetings on Monday mornings?
And just like draining all sucking the
oxygen out of their own life out of.
That's where a lot of people start
taking medication.
Yep.
That unhappiness of,
of just what you call quote unquote real
life,
there's been a structure that's put in
place that we've all sort of shuffled
into that doesn't serve us and it
doesn't serve most people.
You have Wim Hoff on last night,
you know,
he is a telling me about him.
He's amazing,
but one of the things he and I were
talking about,
he was.
He gave me his number about what did he
say?
Like seven percent of people or
something like that.
Do things that are creative with her
life.
What?
Seven percent,
70 percent world.
I don't know.
Let's,
let's get crazy and say it's 15 percent.
That's really small.
It is.
Well,
here's the thing.
One hundred percent of kids are
creative.
It's true.
Like my kids,
they're both.
They're both always do.
My young kids,
they're both always painting or drawing
or doing something in my older kid does
music,
so there's so much creativity that they,
they feel drawn to it and all that stuff
is something that every kid does.
Yep.
Every kid draws shit.
Every kid plays with clay.
Every kid make stuff with legos.
You all like put things together,
you mind,
but somewhere along the line we're
stuffed into this structure that doesn't
serve us.
Then if we feel like we have to do it
because we've been shuffled through
school and into college and then we're
in debt and then we have to take
opportunities and these opportunities is
a good opportunity,
you know?
It's a good,
good career.
Yep.
It's horrific.
It is an end like,
to go back to what you were saying
earlier,
like these,
these systems that we've built are so
antiquated and so outdated from politics
to the school system and it all needs
change and we're seeing it start to,
you know,
ever seen it start to.
I think that the way we educate kids,
the way we relate to add and all these
things,
I think so much of add is like the
current system and the way kids are like
confined in this classroom and have to
follow these rules and sit still all day
like it.
There's no nurturing of creativity.
Right?
Um,
so I think over time a lot of this is
going to start to change.
I hope so because we just can't squat.
I see this with kids all.
I have three nephews and I see the same
thing.
They're so creative and they're
confident.
They don't care what other people think
of them,
you know,
they don't have a lot of fear.
They and,
and when they do do something creative,
they don't judge it and go,
oh,
is it good?
Like they just enjoy the process and
that starts to phase out as we get older
and we get obsessed with other people
thinking isn't good enough and is this
safe and will this please my parents and
like,
will I be able to make money this way?
And we just get so disconnected from
that childlike creativity and wonder and
curiosity and,
and kind of no fear and faith in
ourselves that we just get stuck in this
kind of checklist.
Tassel wearing life.
I think it's another tassels,
tassels,
our enemy.
I think there's another thing that we
need to consider and this is really
important to people that are like,
well,
this is bullshit,
dreamer talk.
Listen to this because this is real.
That corporate worlds only been around
for less than 100 years.
This is a new thing in modern life and
modern life is new in terms of the
length of time human beings have been
alive.
This is a new thing and it doesn't serve
us and maybe with technological
innovation and robots and automation and
all the different shit that's coming
down the line,
maybe there'll be less and less
opportunities for you to work a slave
job and you'll have to do something
creative.
It will be more and more compelling,
but this world that we've structured
that doesn't serve us is incredibly
recent and it's not.
It's not rigid.
Like you don't have to do it.
Right,
right.
But it seems like you do.
It seems like you do.
What's actually really cool about
millennials,
you know this,
the generation that's now like 20 to 35,
36 ish.
That's one of the things I talk about is
generational diversity and millennials
and they're demanding a different kind
of workplace.
They're more likely to take a job where
they have more creativity.
The culture is like less cubical base.
They have more freedom than a job with
the salary and the benefits and they're
not relating to work in the same way.
They're really questioning the old
paradigms there.
I don't understand like why do I have to
be there from nine to five if I can like
get this done at home,
you know,
a certain amount of time and a lot more
of them are starting their own
businesses and doing the more
traditional path.
So I think we're already starting to see
it change because we have a generation
that's huge.
I mean the millennial generation is
ginormous and there they are demanding
different things from work and making
different choices already.
So it's already shifting.
Already shifting.
Yeah.
I also think another thing that's
bullshit is the amount of time that's
required to make a living just to
survive.
I mean how many people are barely being
able to feed themselves and housed
themselves and they're giving up their
entire day and their entire week and you
get.
If you're lucky,
you get that Saturday,
Sunday off,
but most of the time on Saturday and
Sunday if you have an office job,
you have some shit that you brought home
with you that you have to sort through.
Yeah,
that it's the whole payment systems
crazy and you see like these instead of
celebrities making all this money just
by posting pictures and you've got
somebody going to a job like nine to
five day after day after day,
barely scraping by.
It's just,
I don't know.
Well what freaks me out as people that
just move money around and they make
billions.
Like think about like hedge fund people
and people that like,
what are you doing?
You're moving numbers around and you're
making numbers and how much,
how much are you extracting while you're
moving stuff around.
It's the like.
I had this conversation with this woman
who was a staunch Republican who was
telling me that the minimum wage,
I was so ridiculous.
She was so adamant that you can't raise
the minimum wage.
I'm like,
why not?
She's like,
was $15 an hour?
It would crush businesses.
It would do this or do that.
I'm like,
well,
other people disagree like you don't
know whether or not that is.
I go,
do you want to work for less than 15
bucks an hour?
She's like,
well,
these are entry level jobs and this and
that.
I'm good.
You're still requiring an hour of
someone's time.
If your job,
if you ever,
if you have a business and your business
can't pay someone $15 for an hour of
their time,
your business is bullshit.
It's bullshit.
Or you have too many employees or
you're,
you know,
you're not,
it's not set up right,
but you're the person who's at the
lowest rung of the food chain to take
the hit.
Not The business.
Like if you have a business,
you came and pay someone $15 for a whole
hour of working.
How much money are you generating and
why do you need all this business and
why don't you know as employees do it
yourself.
It's not,
it's not an efficient business and I
wonder what's going to happen with
automation and with,
you know,
they're,
they're talking about like a tremendous
amount of jobs that are being done right
now by people that are going to be done
by robots and it's just a matter of
time.
Yeah.
So it's even more important to nurture
your creativity and know what you can do
besides rely on the man or the
corporation or whatever it is.
Because I think a lot of people think
that safety and economic security is in
that is in working for someone else and
working for a quarter,
getting a good job of climbing the
ladder.
Shoot your brains out,
jumping off a building.
Yeah.
It's just,
we don't have that much time.
This is,
this is not,
this is not a long run.
It's really not.
It goes by really some 49 and I feel
like it was 20 yesterday.
It just,
it just happens.
And next thing you know,
I'll be 59 and next thing you know,
I'll be 69.
You know,
and I'll be able to close my eyes and
hear the yawning grave.
It's coming.
It's coming for all of us.
Yep.
You gotTa have fun.
GotTa have fun while you're here.
If in any way possible.
I agree.
I always say that I think regret is far
worse than risk far like I,
I'd rather take risks in my life than
regret playing it safe or staying in
situations that I knew weren't,
you know,
for me,
I mean it.
It's scary.
Yeah.
And there's no guarantee,
but at least you do it.
That's where she comes from.
The.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like the scary stuff.
Like,
Ugh,
that's what forces you to move.
And that's what gets things done.
Exactly.
Every two years I throw away my act and
I write a new one.
Yeah.
I do a special,
like my netflix special.
I abandoned all those jokes and I have
to write a whole new one.
Fucking terrifying.
It's the worst,
but I keep doing it and every time I do
it,
it gets better.
If I keep doing it,
I keep focusing on it.
I'm all that terror and fear of taking
that chance.
It makes,
makes me get better at it and that's a
pretty minor thing because it's not like
that much financial concern and I'll be
okay,
but for someone to take a chance
financially and take a chance their
future and they don't really know what,
what the future holds.
It's not like they have all these things
to fall back on.
That's when you fucking dig.
In fact,
that's when you make things happen and
if you don't,
you just.
You just.
You just stay soft and lazy.
Yeah.
Then you never really discover your true
potential.
If you just stay comfortable.
Christina's people out there right now
that are listening,
that are getting fired up there.
Listen this right now,
they're jogging in place and you're
like,
God damn it.
I don't want to listen to Christine.
Take a chance.
It's good,
right?
Yeah,
it's really good.
It's really good,
but don't just like you just broke the
letter.
Can you really end it?
But don't feel motivated,
like actually like commit to one thing.
What's one thing you can do to start
shifting your life?
Is it,
like I said,
finding that hobby?
Is it like having a conversation with
your boss?
Is it going after that creative
endeavor,
like just start.
That's the other thing.
Like people think they have to know all
the steps.
It's like I want to get to the second
floor,
I'm at the bottom of the staircase and
like I think I just have to jump to get
there.
No,
like you go step by step by step,
just like you'd walk up the staircase so
you don't have to know it all at once.
It's just taking that first step and
then that leads to another and that
leads to another and like you said,
like it's so scary moments where you
find your grit and you find your
potential and you find out how you
respond to adversity and you find your
true gifts and you can only do that in
uncertainty and when you're
uncomfortable,
maybe she'd be a clarity advisor.
The clarity advisor,
like of psychic.
No,
no,
no.
Clarity.
Yeah.
What a psychic wouldn't be a cleric.
This is my new.
Oh,
Gotcha.
I clarity advisor.
That's good.
I like that.
It's a little wordy.
It's not perfect.
It's we're getting closer to step step.
There's something there like you're.
You don't.
One thing that I tell people that I
think is really important,
it's helped me a lot,
is write the things down that you need
to do.
Make a checklist as far as your day like
the best way to get shit done is to
stare that Goddamn list and say,
all right,
today,
did I work out?
Did I write?
Did I do this?
Did I do that?
Then take care of that stuff,
right?
All that stuff that you need to do,
do it at the beginning of the day or do
it when you go to bed at night,
sometimes even better before you go to
bed at night.
Set your intention for the next day.
Say,
I'm going to get all this shit done
right out.
Give Yourself Fifteen,
20 minutes.
You have it.
Everybody's got 15 minutes and then
write it down,
put it,
put it on a piece of paper and the next
day check that shit off.
Yeah.
Do those things and if you could just
get in the habit of doing that.
It's so easy to avoid because people
love to just be lazy.
They love the distraction of doing
nothing
insane.
They don't have time.
Yes,
and saying they don't have time,
but.
But that is one that has been incredibly
beneficial to me is writing things down
and making a list and forcing myself to
check all the shit off.
It's on that list.
Yeah,
and doing the things you don't always
feel like doing and and also being
accountable that people like having
somebody that's like calling you and
being like,
did you do it?
Like did you do it?
Did you show up for yourself because it
takes momentum.
You are they making these kinds of
changes?
You have to build momentum and if you
have that checklist and you're doing
that,
that one thing every day and maybe the
first thing you're going to do is commit
to making a list everyday.
That's a great step.
Once you start showing up for yourself
every day and doing that and checking
things off the list,
you start build self trust.
You start to have more integrity with
yourself.
You start to build momentum and then
it's easy to take the next step and do
the next thing,
but without that momentum and without
that commitment,
I think people just expect their life to
change like this and like we've talked
about this a lot,
like it just doesn't,
but those little steps,
they start to make you feel better too
because you start to feel like,
oh my gosh,
I'm not doing the same thing over and
over because that really is insanity.
But went on Einstein,
who said insanity is doing the same
thing over and over again expecting a
different result.
I think it was like that.
That to me is crazy.
Making
it is and also there's a thing that
people have to be aware of in that is
the trap of falling back into old
patterns because they offer you comfort.
That happens to a lot of people that
want to lose weight.
Losing weight is a big one.
They start,
they start off good,
they start losing weight,
they start looking great,
and then somewhere along the line,
that old pattern calls to them,
this is how I'm fucking
donut,
man.
You've won or you've earned a donut
krispy kremes get a couple of them and
some big deal tomorrow you get back on a
track and you just never do.
You never get back on track and it's,
it's,
it's really common for people,
whether it's cigarette smoking or you
know,
fill in the blank,
whatever it is.
Old Patterns are really hard.
They're really hard to avoid because
they offer some sort of bizarre comfort.
Yeah.
They're like coping strategies and so
many ways.
I mean so many people eat or smoke or
whatever for comfort or to self soothe
themselves and so they can either make a
new year's resolution and lose the
weight and then if they haven't found
another way to cope with life when
things get hard or
someone upsets them or whatever,
they were going to turn to that old
coping device because they haven't dealt
with the issue underneath what made them
overeat or drink or smoke in the first
place.
Yeah,
and it's also when you're filled with
angst and she's.
All these things are fucked up in your
life.
There's something about those old
patterns like give you a big hug.
Yeah,
they do that like a warm fuzzy blanket,
but it's really disgusting.
Covered with bacteria.
Good way to look at it.
If people want to get ahold of you,
how do they do that?
How do they go about that?
Oh,
well,
expectation hangover is my last book.
Christine Hassler,
instagram.
Facebook.
On twitter.
There's no he and Christine because
twitter is screwed up and they don't let
you have.
That's not even a long name.
I know.
It's just too long for twitter.
I'll take it up with twitter.
So how's,
what is the spelling?
S T I n h a s s l e r n no,
he on twitter and you can find it on my
twitter because uh,
this day if you go to this day,
what is today?
Today is October 25th.
Oh,
and if you want to listen to me coach
people alive,
I do that on my podcast.
It's called over it and on with it.
People call and I coach them live on the
air.
It's fun.
Beautiful.
You coach people live on the island.
The.
I don't know anything about him with for
the calling.
Oh Wow.
Do you see them or you just hear them to
see him get trolled?
Trolled.
Dude's going to come after this show is
going to happen for sure.
You've been getting people that really
needed advice up until now.
Now you're going to get people that
really listened to this podcast,
but thank you very much.
I really enjoyed talking to you.
I really appreciate it.
There's a lot of fun folks.
A cnx week.
Lots of good stuff coming.
See Ya.
Bye.